I'll click the word
Huh?
Yeah, that's a lot
Ugh, what an outrage
Who says she hates us? I ain't even booted up yet
Sheeeesh
Oh, I fucking got obsidian over there in the corner
Testing
What are we flanking?
Test done
Waiting to see if I get the results I want
Okay, you know how I know I've gone live because every time OBS YouTube prompts
The YouTube prompts me to say now's the perfect time to put an ad in
At the start of stream you think that's the perfect time to keep viewer retention
Greedy greedy greedy
So I have just been delivered the news that my poor
Clapping without my hands ASMR has been taken down, which is such a shame. I'm currently writing the tweet about it
And so we can I'll read out the tweet that I'm currently writing about it. I've done like a little screenshot
And it says I'm shocked in brackets. I'm not
This is an outrage in brackets. The only outrageous thing was the video idea and the fact I even created it
And then I'm gonna put I feel like this is
unjust
And just for
Jumping up and down for 15 minutes making my cheeks clap
Yeah, yeah, I'm just these nuts in my pants
And my trousers
This is funny is this humorous or is this not
It was a good video how long did it stay up for I
Timed it so it came up for hours ago. I have no idea how long it stayed up for
Like an hour, okay
Well, I am now an even more ASMR debt for the
Subscriber count because I've also apparently passed 8,000 subscribers
Which is terrible news because it means I know how oh seven ASMR videos
Yeah, Azura can't eat a cookie. I'm not allowed to jump up and down and whatever happens happens man
And
So
Something that is yeah, truly
Right. I'm gonna quote tweet my little beauty
And then I will pin what world we're in which is seven. No, it's not it's 388
please
I
Just need to make sure the content your content was removed due to a violation the community guidelines
What do you mean jumping up and down and making math?
None hands clap is a violation
Because it's your first time. This is just a warning, but how big is again your channel's gonna get a strike
And you won't be able to do anything for a week. All right. No, we ain't risking a strike
I got I got a stream record to break
Second strike will prevent you from publishing for two weeks three
Strikes in any 90-day period will result in a permanent removal your channel. Well, I will admit
That's a wee bit dramatic for a bit of cheeky calm
I'm wondering if it was the heavy breathing at one point in the video. I
Went up to the mate and did it so I was breathing heavy
I
Wondering if I was a guy would it be different because obviously female breathing bad bad
male breathing possibly fine question mark. I don't know
because guys heavy breathing is like grunting and then that
Yeah, that's what it is because the actual clapping segment
Maybe I am just absolutely just too far gone
But is it outrageous of me to say the clapping segment? Honestly, it wasn't that bad
Like I just sound like I'm doing a workout and it's like what women aren't allowed to work out on YouTube. Wow
YouTube, that's right
We have to we have to play a few cards here so we can get the chit in the video back
Wow YouTube, that's despicable women can't even breathe and
2024 talk about 1984
I got a couple of 40 years ahead, but I guess not all boo you to boo
All boo time to get YouTube slimed, right?
Let me just check the the actual screenshot doesn't have any information that we want you to stay on YouTube
So make sure you understand and strike review your content or policies every view
Right nothing says Johnny cut was legal name so I can post a screenshot
Understand the strike will expire. Yeah bear expire, right? I've posted it. It's cringe and
Holy shit I
Have I was this I I did not get a lot of sleep last night because I was busy doing
Business business business. Um, oh my goodness
Who the fuck says it's hard to like talk to v-tubers are not in I
I didn't believe you
I spoke to two different. Oh wait. I have a timestamp on the video of why I got taken down and before it's the breathing hold on
The video is loading it's gonna show me what part
I
Was the breathing in the air? I knew it was gonna be the breathing in the air
I knew it. You can't you can't breathe on YouTube anymore. What is going on?
Son bizarre says and I've disrupted the buddha tea and factual content policy
It says audio content that's actually be bliss it is not allowed on YouTube
We may make limited exceptions for content that have educational documentary
You know what I should have started that video by saying I knew it was the breathing
I knew it was of course breathing
Oh, and I need to take should I submit appeal?
Submit appeal
Well, it's a bit. No, I can't put a message in the appeal explaining that I'm a man, and I'm just a man breathing
No
YouTube the only downfall you need to let me explain that I'm a man
I'm a man. Let me breathe. Okay. Well, it's not happening, but we are gonna take the YouTube training
We're gonna take it live
I'll read out what I can see right now. SIGI uploads content of people using
That is a violation I can't even read that out. That's how much of a violation that is chase
In an official music video for a record labor a singer walks through the streets of a carnival the singers costume
consists of a bedazzled
And and it cut and it covers everything
No, it's not a violation because music videos can get away with everything
Remember when Belle Delphine uploaded her music video and I got taken down and then everyone was like hold the
phone a minute if
Nicki Minaj can come out here when nothing but
A bit of tooth floss. Why can Belle Delphine not do it?
I don't know if you remember when that the internet was in complete uproar and then Belle Delphine's video actually got restored
Because YouTube had to back off and admit that record labels had the most
Favourable upload terms. Hey, there's nudity in some in
Some music videos as well. There's just straight up because the record labels can get away with it
Yeah, well, we're actually on the subject
YouTube didn't think I forget all these little violations you do against the community. I'm in the know. No, you I'm in the know, right?
Brian manages a museum YouTube channel each episode is a different tech
topic about
Ancient Japan at one point Brian shows a painting from the 18th century in which people commit
She explains wait, I thought said Brian
She explains the name of the artist the title of the painting this video doesn't violate the policy because it's giving
information about stuff
Check
Yeah, I'm not even reading this stuff properly a movie has a bench all seen in it
Which the lead character are in their
Undies the characters get into bed and under the covers they participate in inking a
Fan uploads a reaction clip of the scene the video description has the name the director lead actors the year
It was produced and there's nothing
Bexwell about it. No, this isn't a violation then
Okay
Fat question five of seven. We're almost there. We're almost there five or seven
Tyler uploads a video from his Safari vacation where he saw two lions
Meeting with one another what he films the meeting and from afar titles lines meeting in the world in the video
Description he describes the type of lion. No, it's not violation. It's just a discovery channel question mark. Yeah, that's correct
Okay, I thought that a comedic prank channel uploads a video in which the creators test how far they can throw different
Objects after throwing different types of food. They start throwing
Bexwell boys a
And of all sizes
This video violates because it uses
Bexwell boys isn't allowed
if the video violates policy because
The video doesn't violate policy
It doesn't violate because the toys aren't being used the way they're supposed to
Hello and before I got it right. I got it right. See I knew I say everyone wonder
How do you know YouTube things as well? I don't have one limited ads video nor stream
That is the gospel truth
It turns out my let me hold it didn't violate the
Ads policy and it's not limited ads. Well, I'll get right
Sorry, sorry, I'm trying to get right to say a news organization uploads a segment about
Spanking. Oh wait, I just said the word anyway
They show adults engaging in banking with clothes and different devices from hands to whip the video title and description
Explain the talk and who's engaged topic and who's engaging in the act within the video with the news reports
Prevides in-depth detail about the bettish and the science behind it
it doesn't
It doesn't violate the policy because it's
Educational check
We've got a seven for seven nice work. You've completed the training
We appreciate you taking your time to help us keep YouTube safe. I'm the one that's a menace on YouTube
Oh, I just I just burped and coughed at the same time and
Your warning will expire on the 19th of September. Wow. That's a long punishment
If you violate the policy again, you're just straight up get a strike if you violate a different policy
You'll get a warning for the different categories of policies
well
Well, I tried my baby. I tried my baby
I'm on a warning now. So that's Emmy on a warning
For being outrageous. I will admit Emmy. You were being a wee bit outrageous. Um
Can I pin it what world we're in
Coot Azura got done in for a cookie and I got done in because I had the audacity to breathe whilst doing physical exercise
James
LKC lick lick James lick. Is that your name? Thank you for the gifted membership
James lick. Is that it? I can't read it
But yes, I successfully completed YouTube program at programming, right? We are in
World oh my god all
Viewers are speculating on why YouTube video titled strong a video was removed the video was popular and viewers are upset and I couldn't read it in time
We are in world 380 for free and I think we're doing winds today
Wings
Um
Now this is not an endurance stream
Oh, but Stranny if you stream longer than two hours technically
It's an endurance stream because less than two hours is the average reach of your stream time, right? Okay. Well, I get your point, but
The long and short of it is I've probably only got four hours or we're gonna redirect into another veal or girl
Okay, I have no idea who or what streaming today
So actually well, I'm at it. I'm gonna check who has actually stream it
I don't know if it's gonna be two hours. I don't know if it's gonna be four hours
Because I need to go offline
To go for a nap
This is three eight nine straight. How the fuck do you how did you find me if I'm in the wrong world?
We in a member's world man. We rich up in here
380 believes it I
Saw you loading back in he knows my every move the reeflings. He's so mind-broken and corrupted. He knows
He's waiting for me an edge bill
Eh she bees in two and him he's in four and has a class. I thought okay
Then I don't really want to read into a collab with outside
That sounds to I don't want to read into a collab with an outsider
No, it's not like that. It's because I've been he I don't know I just feel like it's not like it
Okay, I do these reeflings calling all reeflings. Hey, we're in world 380 blazing
It's a choice. Oh
It's two and four hours of sleep and say oh
Mass sleep. I oh my god. It's the Gluck Gluck ghost
It's the Gluck Gluck. We're you the one that was asking for like a million GP for
I
Like shears when we did the sheer quest. Hey, hey, I'm standing on. I'm standing on. Whoa. Whoa. Whoa. Whoa. What was this about?
That was like a big one. Whoa
You also say hot the fresa young hot the fresa. Yeah, I know my mood or it's in Oh, uh
I used to be able to say your mom but hot the fresa just means shut your mouth and French it's female a boost and
Scots is just shot it or like a way you go like yeah, I'm gonna take a drink of my tea
So many streams. Yes, we're in stream that was it. Um, I
Am playing duck game with mercy and we're gonna say sorry. It's not called duck game. Oh, it's called goose game and
Fuck me. Why is untitled goose game so expensive?
Um
Um, but yes
Wrong bird so many. Yes. Wait. What was that? I saw that. Oh, you want to trade? Oh, we trade
Okay, nah, I'm door closer. Oh, you're door. Oh, okay. Good morning me right now, but oh
Thank you for the 10
Oh shoot, I'm getting loaded up on wine
Feels wait, didn't you start fresh? How do you have so much money to do? Wines and jugs little reflin
How have you done that? Thank you better for the 10. Good morning for you moment. You're looking very
cuddly
strongy
strong today
What does that mean?
What are you planning on doing?
Oh my god, he's edging me. Okay. I was gonna say I'm getting edged to you
right
so
The long and short of it is
um
Tiny scum I've been doing some mining off camera
a
So I have 10k more as soon as I get off the oh get soft ground exchange
Okay, gee reflings are now rich in this game. Okay. It didn't take them long to start to start the business
Refling's great and for I go take your grand oh me
Relax your man. Take your time with me
Oh, I can click. Oh, I can't remember what the strats were supposed to be. I'm so sorry
Wait, what is it escape and then space bar to combine the items and then that's how I do it
So basically we're just gonna muck about and do wines
Um, I have absolutely fantastic news for strongy cuddles dot choville or whatever the fucking title is
um
I
May or may not have found myself
uh
A clipper and she's a girl
I have sent her a te
Is like joke on my freaking breath
I sent her a big batch. I've sent her a batch of five pre-made and six highlights on stream
So I just want to say special shout. Yes a she clipper. I'm leaving kidding actual woman moment. I can't believe it. Um
I just want to say special shout out to anyone who uses youtube's clip
Feature if I ever do anything funny mildly humours. Let's be honest. I'm no funny
If I do anything mildly humorous that makes you blow a little bit of air out of your nose
Please use youtube's clip feature. I can see what you clip and it basically means I can pass it on
to
The the the lovely lady. Um, I might actually introduce you to her if if all goes well
Um, but I mean she has an outstanding portfolio. She's worked for idle and you know those like super hyper idle n click
Super idle. No, sorry. Uh idle n clips are like edited for like running all that
It basically haven't you learned from your ASMR stop breathing. It isn't doing you any favours literally. I'm scared to stream ASMR now. I'm like
I can't even fucking breathe can I man? Like oh my god
Clipper debut when oh, she's fantastic. Honestly the portfolio is insane
Um, and they also do highlight reels if I wanted a highlight clip of something
So I might ask for buckshot roulette highlight, but I don't know how busy they are. I had to message
Oh, I guess I'm like so I feel so cringy when I mess up like
Hi, I'm strony cuttles from veal lure
Um, I've seen that you've gotten a really impressive like I always start off with a compliment
Um, I always thought I'm like, oh my god, your portfolio is like so impressive and I was like, I'm so sorry
but I don't know what your
Your rates are as well as if you have any new client spots because if you didn't know most people
When they're established
They most likely have a one-on-one editor highlighter that does everything like consumes the content and produces it for clips type thing
And I was like, I don't know if you have any space and she replied back and followed me instantly and I was like
Are we?
So, um, I have like 12 shorts being produced
Um, I'm currently waiting on
So there's like three editors between the girls as well, which makes things a lot easier
Like I have my own dedicated clipper like I commission her separately for whatever clips I like get of the girls type thing
um
Oh my god slime girl
Right, right, right
If I see one slime girl complain one more time
Don't get
13,000 wanes
Thank you so much reflood. Holy crap
What the hell I literally have been like princes carry through this entire
Like segment 13,000 we want a slime girl
You can get she be can have an alternative halloween slime girl outfit. I it's absolutely fine with me
I couldn't be less of a rat's horse
I am not having a slime girl. What would the design be? She doesn't even have any april
She doesn't have armor. She doesn't have anything. I have no interest in it. I've in
Reflins
And his banana
My ledger banana
I'll eat it right now, right. Don't think I won't eat your banana in edgeville. Oh, it's bruised
Oh, it is bruised
Bro, right. I don't think anyone needs to give me any more supplies question markers. What is 30,000 wine?
Is that like I'm done a bruised banana. No, I don't hate slime girls
I absolutely adore suzu from monster musume. The problem is
Think of it in terms of a vtuber model
Nacos one color a wee bit of a hairstyle and that's it like
What else am I supposed to date with that? Sorry? It's just no one. It's just no one. It's not appropriate
with um
Oh
Excuse me 30,000 only gets me to 91
Oh hell no, this can't be jigsaw. No a school uniform. Mercy's uh already in that
If you didn't notice mercy is in a student uniform that was by design
It's very messed up and but she is in a japanese school girl
April if that's your thing. I purposely put that in because I know it's a lot of people's things
Uh, that wasn't that was a production note on mercy's design
Right, I'm good at trying to chug my uh me me humble
Thingy, but yes, uh special. Thank you to anyone who does clip me via youtube's so higher than 91 actually
Can we get my higher?
So
Uh, which one was your favorite monster musume?
Uh puppy
Uh, I would absolutely adore harpy. I love
Love icy
Um, I am not going to pretend ac's hips may or may not have been influenced by papi from monster musume
Um, I love the big hips big arm thing going on. Absolutely adore it truly
Absolutely adore it, um
We are
Uh, I don't really know if I should say it got thank you again to the incredible tipper yesterday
aim for the the gen two production tip that was a an insane amount of money
Um
For that you've actually you pretty much paid off the concept artist. Um for that kind of money. Um
There has been
Aces hips exactly there has been a mild update now. I keep it on the download
Don't want the don't want anyone to be upset, but um, there are two designs
that are
Pretty much accepted
um
We just need the artist the modeler the modelers already been contacted. We just need to see what their thoughts are what they can do
Um, we're looking into possibly custom poses
um
for
each girl it's um
It's an interesting thing to do. Um any hints, uh
I don't think I can give any hints mercy actually is very familiar with one of the designs. Um
I
She actually got quite fond of one of the concept designs. Um
But I don't know if she wants to talk about it or if I should let her talk about it
Because it's like a design that doesn't even I have I am going to see if I can get the girls to
Um
I'm like the girls to what
I
Five thousand subscribers actually I think we're all approaching five thousand subscribers, you know that
Sorry, I'm trying to do like oh, sorry oops
Let's do 14
How does it know to do 14 I never told it to do
Uh, I think the girls are very close. We actually have celebratory
Art work when everyone hits 5k
Azura and icy are coming up
I'm actually going to get them to do an ASMR video which I think will push them over the edge
Obviously Azura we're having a
So we can't put up Azura's meme video yet. Um, but that will definitely help boost Azura a bit
But I am going to send
AC and Azura on their merry way to create me an ASMR script and I'm going to get it up
Is up
Um, because I truly in wholeheartedly believe the girls can clear 5k easily in their first month. Um, I
I'm going to see
Um, emmy the freaking hard worker
She made a thumbnail because her and ac are actually doing a audio collab, which is fantastic
It is going on emmy's channel when she's away on holiday. I can say that emmy broke the news
She going on vacation. Okay. She's going on vacation
And she updated her youtube profile picture so she looks so menacingly evil, which is hilarious
Um, it's actually I will say one thing now don't get me wrong
I'm sure a lot of management's wouldn't like this at all
I like coming online and being like, oh what he's done when I've been asleep
And it's like, oh right. Okay. Every changed her profile on youtube. Like, oh, that's cute. That's sweet. Um
ac made a
Oh emmy made three, uh, twitter audios. She absolutely did
She she gone for it, uh
Pin pals, I do not know what you've done to my cute innocent little sister
She was not like this in the interview stage and I'm getting scared of her. Her power is growing and uh,
Yeah, it's uh, I'm starting to monk us over here. Okay
Innocent
You should have seen her in the interview. She was nothing but polite sweet
She was actually the most inquisitive question wise
Um, you know asking all these different aspects and like, uh, one of the funniest. Oh, I felt like such a flex
Felt like such a flex. Oh, she was like, how how's the company funded now?
It's like the company has been seated. There is no debt. The banks do not own the company. The company is self-owned
Oh, thank you for asking that question emmy. I'm humping on I'm gyrating on my chair right now
Oh the flex. Oh the company's seated. Oh
Absolutely, I don't sorry. I'm a bit too energetic for first thing in the morning, but oh
Oh, how satisfying
Anyway, I do do love me a little interview. I hope the girls couldn't attest that the interviews are probably the most relaxed
Interview they'll ever get in their dying lives. Uh, because it is so unprofessional
I'm like, hi. I'm scottish. If you can't even understand me
Just just ask me to repeat myself and they're like now. I understand you. I've heard you before and I'm like, oh
You're not supposed to hear me before
um
Stroney, literally. I was like company seated. Ah money's all there. Ah, no debts
Oh, I just felt so good. Your energy today is amazing, but you'd think I hadn't oh my god
Aries wants to trade with me
What you got? Oh my god. No way
reef wins
No way guys. I don't think you give me 22
million
great
great, um
It's just called gp. Isn't it gold?
and then
all of
What's this 33,000 wait? Why is it only sorry my apologies?
46 and 40
56. Oh my god. I'm so blind to freaking
um
Wow
How are you guys doing right? Let me finish my tea because it's getting cold
Most energetic scott in half seven half seven in the evening
Uh try four a.m
I literally rolled out of bed 10 minutes. Well 10 minutes before streaming can't be 10 minutes ago because I've already streamed for longer than 10 minutes
um
Yeah, literally
Uh yesterday was a freaking dream. I was like, oh, sorry you want to trade with me? Hold on
Let me clear some inventory space for you real quick. Hey, you cook all of those and you're like 97
We are finishing it next week. I think we're doing elden ring and then we're doing. Oh my god
Wait, you did them wait did it but did you do the math because because it's not right?
Oh my god, you evened it up. That's amazing. That's actually amazing. You evened it up. You're like, no, no get that get that going
Uh, but yes yesterday was a fever dream. So I was like, uh, isn't it hard to like
You know talk to other v-tubers and stuff like why is it because you see so many tweets that are like
I'm so shy of meeting other v-tubers
Reply under this tweet and I'll get back to you. I'm like, oh, it's actually that hard to like kind of message folk
No, I just sent follow requests. Uh, and then low and behold, uh
Some girls followed me back and I've asked for two ASMR collabs like a cheeky shape
And complimented the girls because they've been so nice. Uh, and I've seen their content
I'm quite impressed by all their content on that. Uh, so I've been a cheeky shite and asked for two ASMR collabs from two different
agency v-tubers
So I don't know how everyone's fucking greeting on twitter being like, it's so hard to be nice to folk
If you go in there and state your business boom
People it's almost like people reply instead of the hey, hey, we're both v-tubers
No, if you're both v-tubers that doesn't they make you pals
That's like saying all postmen of the world are best pals because they deliver the post. No, that's not how it works
Uh, I think I think all those tweets are folk going hey and someone's dms and they're like, I can't be arse with you right now
That's my only like that's the only thing I can ascertain
All right, just spell my name out sin. I'm not even asked you for an ASMR collab yet
So you can't even not sin it's actually so sin's really easy to talk to literally I was like, sorry delaying your thing for a
A couple of weeks because my dad's coming over and she's like, oh fuck you
And we've got like shot colors on standby. Right. Let me finish this
Oh
99 prayer after cutting you must be joking
I bought membership for this by the way and you can do wines for free
I'm so sorry if I tricked anyone into buying runescape membership
I thought we were gonna cook like those little weird starfish. Oh, where am I going? I don't know
I've gone over here now for some reason. I don't know how I perfectly collect that bank
But I'll come back over refunds. Give me a second. I just I wanted to collab with my
My favorite is a married man. You get your succubus ways. Oh away from him. She hates this. I don't I'm just dumb
But I actually miss click. I don't know how I perfectly miss click that that bench though
Um
If you didn't know sin sister
70 freaking nine. That's fantastic
um
Sin is actually a retired succubus. Yeah, that sells a one. Oh, oh, oh, right. You want to start with? Oh, that's a no
man. All right. All right. All right. Um
Literally level 79 we're getting there. Um
If you didn't know sin
sister's lore
is actually
She's a retired succubus and if you look at her loading screen
If you may have never noticed this because I didn't notice it until like the 18th billion stream
I had watched of hers. I was watching her supermarket stream a while ago. It's fucking hilarious, honestly. Um
Her loading screen has the person that summoned her dead on the floor with a smash keyboard over their head
Look at that next time you see her loading screen because I never noticed that detail for the longest time
After cooking it should be construction. So so shawty can design a cute house
Always gonna play hide and seek in the house with you guys
Monka is literally sin. That's our father-in-law. How could you?
Um, but yes turns out communicating with v-tubers is really easy if you just don't waste their time
So, um, if you are a shy v-tuber that is lurking in the shadows and you always want to collab with someone
Just say hi
Just say hi name. I'm this person from this agency if you're from an agency
Uh compliment them and say that you uh something that you enjoy about their content
Um, so it shows that you're not just like messaging them to collab like it shows like I've actually consumed your content
I've appreciated it from afar. You know that kind of level of thing
um
And then just say hey, this is what I would love to do if you don't have time completely understand because you're incredibly busy
It is that easy peasy. No, I think we've got enough wine and grapes. I'm gonna be honest
Oh, we're getting steaming on the kebab. Why is everyone giving me a kebab?
Is this my breakfast? Thank you for feeding me reflin. I got a kebab
I think I have enough now that keyboard
Literally, literally me
Uh, and while you're at it, didn't you upload breathing ASMR by the way? I got a violation for clapping my cheeks
In an ASMR video apparently it lasts it was up for an hour
Um, I pretended to put in an appeal but uh, yeah, it's not good. It's not happening
It is not happening at all, but hey, hope that's it's how the cookie crumbles
That's how the cookie crumbles. I literally missed it. I'm pure raging. Don't worry
I'll send you the audio custom for you baby cakes. It was literally me like taking my I kid you not
I took my prel off like my weaponry um and uh my plate skirt and all of that
And uh, I basically got coconut oil and started jumping up and down which creates a clapping noise
So I called it clapping without my hands ASMR and no
I think it's hilarious. I don't care what anyone says. That's the funniest idea. I've probably ever came up with
Um, and I will never be able to top that
Uh at all
So unfortunately my ASMR debt has increased to seven videos yet again
So I wasn't there. I was there. It was great. I do apologize for anyone who missed it. Um, I
I
For you for those who missed it
I will buy premium
On my alt twitter so you can listen to it for free. Okay deal
But in return
You have to say
Thank you. Mommy. I'm not worthy. Okay. That's all. Yeah. You just have to take. Thank you mommy. I'm not worthy
And then you will start to learn
the uh
You'll start to learn the ways. Okay
It is on patreon right now. I do use my patreon as a safe
Location that i'm not worthy. I'm not worthy. Uh, look at you groveling
Just for a little audio. You're so cute
Good reefling very good reefling
Um, yes, it is up on patreon right now for my if i'm allowed to plug the patreon. Oh
I am supposed to have wait, um, hold on
Uh, hold on. Oh no
Oh
Where's the uwu market freaking oh for folks sake, I don't think I can search right now
I'm supposed to have a little icon up right now. That's like hey guys
I have merch from uwu market and it goes in the corner and it's tiny
But I can't find the freaking link in the chat. Can someone repost my links
From the uwu market pack. I can't see it because i'm live right now and uh discord is
In streamer mode and I ain't got the balls
To take it off. Thanks. Thanks. Maybe question mark, but don't worry if you're busy girls
I know
I know you work hard kiss
Absolutely
Um, there's a new vtuber agency that's popped up and I've already forgotten the bloody name of it
And the fucking owner of nexus follows me as well. I was checking out his follow man. I'm like, um, this one on here
What's going on here? Um
Uh, no not socks but shout out to socks agency. Um, the owner of socks agency is actually super cool. Um
He sockified all the girls actually so I should probably tweet out about it. Um, but I'm terrible at marketing and all that kind of thing
Uh, no, no, uh, there's a new feature agency. What's that called? It's coming up
They've revealed the designs, but they've said it's not like the finished version of the designs. There's four girls to a generation. Um
But it's really interesting like I'm here. I'm sorry, but I'm here rooting for the underdog
I'm here for these new agencies these like crater owned agencies like I think it's very clear like, um
You know people are getting a bit sick up and fed. Um, is it sick up and fed? Yeah
People are getting isn't that shit postage? Oh, no, no, no, I weave it's a bit shit posty
But um, I got to like basically
It sounds silly. I got to interview the uh, the sock puppet agency
um, but um
You'd be surprised how like uh, based it was like behind the scenes. I'm be I can't say anything
But it was very surprising to hear the motivations behind the agency and that
so then it'd be surprised if I'm sucking on sock agencies toes or anything like that because so is a
I've seen everything I've seen so far. I like and I've actually got a
Two girls that were pre-established in one new or starting fresh. I can't remember
Hey there. Hi socks is actually making it real. Yes
um
Uh
Small corporal piled
I think people are getting a bit tired of the endless new wave new wave new wave
This'll this'll help new wave new wave. Well, we have a stock market
Oh, we actually like care about money at the end of the day not the talent
When people can see right through that you're only here for money with your talents and all that and these are
Real people these are real people with real lives real issues going on behind the scenes
uh, people get tired um and
Stains start getting die die
Die gets casted and stains remain you cannot wash away certain stains
So it's very interesting to see now. Don't get me wrong. Uh, your agency's tiny stroney
You're using even 5k yet fucking relax right mate fucking relax. Jesus christ. Um
Um
Like i'm actually going to do a short which is controversial. It's terrible. I know are you ready for the short?
Uh, but but burn the yacht
Oh, no, you said but the yacht. Sorry. Uh, sorry. It's a bit programmed in me to burn that yacht for some reason. Um
I actually am doing a incredibly controversial. It's not controversial to me. Um, because there's a very popular youtube short
And it goes how much do you v-tubers make?
Um, but obviously inside the short no money
Is mentioned at all
So i'm going to do the controversial thing after a month
I'm going to show how much I earn in a youtube short so people can get a grasp of like
Hey, this is how much you can earn if you put your whole pussy into it. Um
And it'll be very interesting to see what the response is
I feel like the response from people who aren't really a fan are going to be like
Uh, or this is
This is an obscene amount of money and then the people who are like, holy crap. You're killing it type thing. Um
Yes, I did enjoy a short from grin pen rose that was like how much do v-tubers make sorry to name
them directly
But it was like if you're going to title that and not tell the money, bro
Let me let me cut to the fucking chase and i'll show you how much money i've made. Okay. Let me cut to the chase
Um, and i'll do it since everyone's so shy to be like, yeah a surprise surprise
I actually make money. Uh, I make a livable income with what I do type thing
And before anyone's like, uh, you're just flexing your money. Oh, that's just like showing off your money and whatever
I was like, no, I still like that either you you get a short. That's all artsy farts saying like all
Oh, you'll never know how much a vtuber actually makes or you get my short where i'm like, this is how much i made
This is how it works. Did it did it like
You're trying to pick pick pick your path. Okay, because it's not even a path of an illusion at this point
It's like either you want transparency or you want artsy fartsy
a
Watching a short for a minute and don't even get the answer to the freaking thingy flex that money strony you deserve it
Um
Yeah, revealing the secrets laws. See I don't
I don't think it's like bad or anything, but um
Yeah
Edging versus releasing in short
No
That's hilarious
But it's true though. Why like I was gonna do a short
That's like a breakdown of the model prices and everything
And because there's so many like how expensive are vtuber models?
And then it doesn't say how much the model freaking costs in the end and then it's like oh, but toggles are expensive
Toggles are additional fee. Yeah nice shit toggles are additional expenses because you have to get more artwork for it
You have to do different calibrations for it. Like just tell us if oh i'm getting so angry i'm burping
Just tell us tell us stop. Stop freaking edging us on vtuber like shorts. Why?
Why am I like I shouldn't feel like i'm like having to freaking get blood from a stone
How much are vtuber models and then oh it depends on your budget?
You can also get these free ones as well and it was like, okay
Well, thanks for absolutely nothing like i'm gonna do a big breakdown on the model prices of the girls and all of that
Azura actually I have a short for her to make but I need her voice
um
I was basically gonna do like guess how much
Are vtuber models costed or like who is the most expensive vtuber model at valer type thing?
And then just reveal all the prices basically
Yeah, I don't like the freaking non
I don't like the the the
The short being a question and then the short doesn't even answer the question now. Don't get me wrong
I understand that is that is content 101 you suck them in you give them a non answer and then you scroll away
No one has time to be angry because your attention span is already gone to the next video once you've finished it
Agencies hate her for this one simple trick. She actually tells the behind the scenes
um
Like I my I sent the short girl. I'm not gonna say her name until like I know all is good
And she's fine if I mentioned her name being my editor T
My not my editor being my clip clip editor that I commissioned. I she doesn't belong to me
Okay, she doesn't belong to me, but she's I think she's Australian actually
um
Not me sending messages at 4 a.m. So, uh, anyway
No, um
You play it safe. Well, they get it. Yeah
And before my like straightforward shorts flop, but if I did an edging
Uh one where I'm like, I don't tell the tell the full story. It gets like a cabillion views
I can see that happening
But yes, I actually need to borrow Azura's voice because I'm going to get her to do a
How much do veiler
Uh models cost. Actually, there's this really popular sound right now and it goes. Let's go gambling
Oh dang it
And I was gonna do that about opening up a VJ for agency and it's just like bank account goes down artists over deadline
everything pushed to the day before debut
Unlimited unlimited stress unending stress like that kind of thing. Um, but I need to make it. Yeah, they're like, oh dang it
Oh, I was gonna do that and like a really quick breakdown of what it was like
um
But yeah, I was one of them have a commission done in having a commission done on time impossible literally
There's like this jigsaw meme where it's like
Uh and for your last challenge have your girl go and it's like, oh hell nah jigsaw
Um literally that but for artists complete your complete your uh commission on time even though you've been given ample time
Sorry, but I cannot tell you I feel like I have been very fair with what uh
Timelines I have given people and like nothing happened. I'm going to lie
Oh
Forgive me reflands. I do love a good run in a ramble. I really do
Um unlimited stress. Well, literally if you ever want to be stressed fucking open up a VJ for agency
It is the perfect
Perfect amount of stress
You could do that self-deprecating applying a corporal short with be allure is jackpot. It's true ready
Um
Yeah, I
Oh, maybe I should do like controversial ones on purpose where it's like
It's like we want to burn the yacht
We want earth like I want to see girls actually get money that they're given like I want them to have good cuts
But then I feel like everyone will be like and you just hate bg sandy. No, I don't hate bg sandy
I hate corporate greed. You are you are crossing the lines
Sistens you are crossing the lines. We don't like corporation greed out here. That's it. That's literally it
I love the insider. Yeah, I think it's terrible. I know
Since that you could use a massage. Are you offering refland? Hmm. Are you offering?
I have just clocked your fucking profile picture. It's a refling with ryan gosselin in the picture. That is hilarious
I've changed my setup so I can see you guys better without my glasses on
Um, so I can actually see your profile pictures now like I can see
um
Like what your profile picture consists of a lot easier now. Yeah, he drives by the way
We don't like the yacht man in the end part. No, like I understand business is business. Don't get me wrong, but
um, I think with how personal and
kind of non-tracks
Transactional streaming should be like
You know how like I always get sensationalized that like this girl demanded from her viewers
That they give her a five dollar sub and she says they're all cheap asses and all that kind of thing
um
type idea
Like it shouldn't feel that transactional
But when you have a corporation behind it that makes that transaction
So apparent that releases their stock that releases public notes about meetings and all of that
I'm like
Mate you're just asking for trouble. Like I don't know if legally
Japanese countries. Sorry. I really struggled to say that there
Uh, Japanese countries like have to release these insider notes or something
But what's going on and what's with these claims that like they're hiring 16 year olds for their pr team or something
Like I don't know what is going on. I probably shouldn't even talk about it because I'm not educated enough to talk about it
Um, and I will acknowledge like hey, I'm not educated. Like I probably shouldn't be but like the you know, you know
you know
Um, it's a smash and grip if I'm am I mistaken in saying there's a new hollow live branch coming
Uh, but they were like forced to interact with the male hollow live branch already
Japanese laws are messed up. They always favor the corporal. Hmm
Yes, I think the rise of content creation owned agencies is definitely swapping in
Um
Debut tomorrow, I think really that's fantastic. I wish them well
Uh, there's no reason to believe they were forced to
I thought they I thought yeah
Oh
Well, uh
Curious curious if they weren't forced to
Of course, I don't know about that
I have reason to suspect that not all their tweets are their own tweets. Um
So I actually wouldn't be surprised if it wasn't even them
Because uh, depending on how generic the tweet is
Me I'm not I'm not convinced. I'm not convinced. I feel like that curate. Mmm. Oh Hannah. Yeah jigsaw. I see two again
That's it. That's the meme
There's a lot of stuff related to japanese corporate structure and how they do things. Oh my god. I
Do you guys ever watch like paulo in japan?
He does like behind the scenes of what it's like to work in like japan and oh my god
Oh my god
These people do not even have time to breathe and the drink culture is so heavy as well
Like if you don't go out drinking with your co-workers after like a 12 hour day
um
A 10 foil scrawny. No, it's not. It's real. It's documented. This is it's actually documented and you can access information at any point
tee he
um
Literally like if you don't go out drinking with your workmates after a 12 hour shift
You're considered to be like a bad sport. You're not a team player
At least youtube won't ban. Oh, right. Oh, okay. Okay. Remember that time I breathed into the microphone and I got a warning for it
good times
That was such a I'm sorry. All I'm gonna say is that video would have went viral
I would have got a cheeky 40k views on that video if it was left off
That's all I'm saying because everyone would have been like what's going on here. Oh, hey, yeah, jigsaw. Bye
Don't even get me started. I started as a um a beachy fan
So literally every corporate beach where I watch save for one leave in the company because of stuff going on
Yeah, no way. There's a lot of unspoken rules in etiquette. So that's absurd would um, we don't oh, no, I don't want to oh, no
I'm too late. It's too late
Ah, it's too late. I got 30k bomb feels good, man
I would want to live in japan, but the work attitude would perish me. Yeah working yourself to death
Is quite literally a thing for corporate. Yeah, I'm sorry. I can't relate to that. I want to retire in hobbiton
I want to tend to
Me flowers. I want to tend to my veggie patch. I want a lovely hearth in the evening when it's cold
I want to let the fire warm up the room and
You know have some cheese
and meat and crackers and fall asleep in my little lounging chair in front of the fire then giggle when I wake up and like
Okay, I should probably go to bed now and then I stuff out the fire like that that's
This is what I if you ever get asked. Oh, what's your ideal job and then you go
I do not dream of labor
That is 100 percent valid and please do not think you are weird otherwise for not naturally
Gravitating towards one specific job. It I have terrible news. You're actually not hardwired to want to do something like that
Um, you I don't know if there's evidence for crop hardwiring because of you know about a full crop is
You know good for you these bots coming in
They kind of look like bots. I ain't going away
A full pantry and a full belly and off to snooze land ago that this is what oh, sorry
This is what I long for a simple life truly
These are all bots or altkins for smithing. Oh, there must be a smithing mine. Oh, wait, there's a furnace right there. I see
Uh a full womb
Base give me the simplest job possible and I can forget about it when it's done
Literally, um, like I've kind of said this
I think I'm gonna get into we like ASMR pop-up shop or angle back into education and all of that
Because like I don't dream of doing nothing
But you know if you're able to remove the stress of like, oh my god, I don't have enough money to pay bills
like
Bruv
You're on cloud nine like imagine just being able to completely
Like understand that you can walk away from your job at any time like if you get treated like shit
Who benefits who benefits from poverty?
Business owners because people will put up with shitty conditions people will put up with overworking themselves
People will put up with workplace abuse, which is rife across the board actually
The bullying doesn't stop at high school. It does not stop at high school
Workplace isolation slash bullying is very much a thing
Um, so do not ever be embarrassed if you are ever a victim to it. Don't ever think oh, we're all adults now
I shouldn't have to go through this. You're right. You actually shouldn't but some people never age never
mature
past that high school mentality of you're slightly different from me
I will treat you differently because of that aspect
I feel I feel uncomfortable because you're different from my persp- persp- perspec-
of normal
like
Money doesn't buy happiness, but cover poverty causes the depression poverty
Poverty begets poverty as well as the system putting place up against you. So like that fucking
Where's that tinfoil hat? Oh, I could actually go on one. Um
Yeah, like did you know they also set the fuel prices for regions?
Did you know they purposefully set the fuel price in american region higher than they do for your
Europe they came together in a council to do this. This is public accessible knowledge like poverty begets poverty
If you don't have a car in america
Fuck you
You can't go anywhere because they don't even have uh, how you call them. I think you guys say sidewalks
There's not even pathing
There's not even pathing to walk to work if you so desired and we're so lucky to even actually that reminds me
I saw a video of this guy
Whose house was right across from his work and he chose to drive to work because he couldn't get
He couldn't physically there was no intersection. There was no traffic lights. There was no way across
We live in a society
I can't believe that every runescape stream just turns into me complaining about society. Oh, but strongy strongy. What's your solution?
What's my solution?
My solution
You ain't gonna like it
No one's gonna like it because I actually don't have a solution
The thing is we have a disease on our hands
And we have to treat the symptoms
But how on earth do you tackle the symptoms on a disease that does not want to be cured?
How do you tackle the symptoms on a disease that does not want to be cured?
There is a patient in the bed right now
That is resisting
Every single ounce of medication you could possibly administer to them
You have a syringe
They move out the way
of that syringe
You try to put in
You try to give them a tablet they cough it up behind your back because the string
Because you can't be watching them. You don't have the power to watch them for 24 hours
You need to go do stuff. You know
You try to put an ointment on their back
It gets wiped off
It's allowed to stay for a couple of minutes, but the ointment is wiped off the patient remains sick
The symptoms are present. The disease is still there. How do you treat that?
We don't know
strongy bringing the tin foil. Is it tin foil time?
For now
Veiler will do its best
That's what sectioning is for
There's a very famous ultra corporal bro that graduated from my uni made as
Very needed medicine go from like 25 to 1k. Yes
I am loving the success stories
I believe there is a pharmacy that is currently on the rise in america
I cannot for the life of me remember it
But they publicly said our markup is like I think 10 us dollars whatever you purchase
We make a 10 us dollar profit on that's it
That's all we ask that covers the infrastructure that covers the insurance that covers the business that covers
Everything of our business. We have a markup of 10 dollars. I cannot remember. Oh shit. Did I get an xp bomb?
Ah, sorry too busy running again
Uh
44 000 xp bomb. Wow. We're almost at 80 feels good, man
Insulin yes the patent for insulin
The gentleman that created it
I I apologize his name evades me at this moment in time
The gentleman sold the patent for one dollar because he believed it should be in the hands of the people if you have type
One diabetes you were born insulin
Resistant you can't do a thing about it
You rely on insulin if you are type 2 you can reverse this through diet exercise change
But you must be incredibly careful and use your doctor's advice in order to um
In order to revert the effects that type 2 diabetes has caused
But insulin patent was sold at one dollar and now is an astronomical fee
I have heard of horror stories of people passing away
No one in my opinion should pass away
for
Diseases um that are out with their control. What do you mean? I believe in health care for all. Oh, is that controversial?
Yeah, relax. I grew up in scotland
Medicine is free if you didn't know medicine and health care is free in scotland
um
But think about the odds exactly. Um, I actually uh almost
that
I may have almost broken the law twice in australia already
Excuse me for being a a bad girl. That's right. I'm a bad girl. You want to hear my bad girl story?
I
may or may not have had to get medicine just for a few things or another like beta block or that kind of stuff from my heart
um and
In scotland you do not pay for your medications. You go to the pharmacy
You hand over your prescription and you walk away with it
I
I think I may have already told this story
The look of horror on and shock on the man that was serving me when I started to put the medication in my backpack
He he couldn't even get any words out because he had never seen such blatant theft before and I was like
Do we have to pay that? I was like like do the australians pay
for medication
and he was like
Yeah, you need to go over there and pay for it and I'm like
Oh
Sorry, uh
In scotland, it's free and like he laughed it off
But like the look in his face was like
And then I also did it twice
And another pharmacy, so I'm probably on a list to be honest
I started walking out the shop and I'm like wait
Wait a minute because like I could see the receptionist looking at receptionist the cashier looking at me
Like with eyes open. I'm like I had to like fucking go up to the desk. I'm so sorry. I'm scottish everything's free in scotland
I feel like repeat and then they always like they're like wait what all medication is free. I'm like, yeah asthma free
Asthma pump. No, you don't get asthma for free asthma and healer is free
Insulin is free. You need iron. You got iron deficiency free if on prescription
You need vitamin deficiency free on prescription like
All of it free and everyone is always so surprised whenever I explain that I'm like it's free everything's free
If you're born with ailments ailments or experiencing illness, it's free
You shouldn't have to pay to make yourself healthier or to make yourself at the optimum that your body can handle
Some folk come out a bit messed up. That's okay. Here's some stuff that'll help you get through the day
You know, some people aren't built for you know a classic nine to five
Some people are built for being a nice little cozy home bed because their body's all messed up and that's fine
That's just the way it is asthma for freak. No America's
America Australia's most wanted literally cannot stop thieving medication
You can't he stopped me man. Can he the actual can he stop me?
If you have to pay for anything at all it's usually a pittance to
Cute room. Oh, did I bring strong it was bragging about this mythical land of scotland?
Do you want to hear another mythical fact about scotland?
Our national animal is a unicorn
I'm an iron horn. Yeah, this isn't an iron horn
For scotland. Yeah
It's a unicorn. It literally is look up right now typing
Scotland's national animal and tell me it doesn't say unicorn
It's a unicorn made up country. It is a unicorn
Don't tell me I'm I'm not fibbing. It's a unicorn. Yeah
They are unicorns are quite name. Um
Our national flower is a thistle, which is a purple
Flower, it's a very unique looking flower. Um, it is spiky. So don't get too close to it. Um
I don't know
I assume the thistle has
Cross continents by now and you you guys have seen a thistle
Seeing unicorns is seeing unicorns as everyone is on the mushrooms
Bre
I don't know who decided that they're like, oh, we're gonna pull a little prank on them prank. I'm John
Made up animal for a made up country. No. Oh my god for real. I love scotland. Yes
You probably wouldn't think a magical horn to create your typically seen on children's lunchboxes, but it's true
The unicorn is the national animal. Yes. I'm I'm horn
It is true
I'm not telling fibbers. Okay. I'm not telling fibbers
prank I'm John. Oh, I love that prank. I'm John
When are you coming to uh, why are you combining dutch?
Uh, when explaining is there German history in scotland? No, there's actually a lot of history between the netherlands and scotland
When it came to the cotton trade, um, if you ever have the pleasure of going to bruge, um
Do not be afraid to take the touristic boat canal rides
Um, they explain all these like cross-reference of history and apparently scotland and the netherlands were pretty hand-in-hand at one
Point which was really nice. Um, don't ask where the netherlands actually sourced the cotton from
Our bell jump for that matter. Um
But, uh, you know all went well, um
Hello, hi for anyone joining. I'm just going on another rant again about society
Hello about us living in a society
Also that I may or may not be a wanted criminal in Australia due to the fact I can't stop stealing medicine. Um
Because it's really hard to
unlearn everything
And it's like hard to unlearn like oh wait medicine costs money. Oh dear
We don't ask those questions
English is a germanic language
Someone said netherlands sourced some and yeah, uh, does netherlands. Oh wait, of course. I'm german when I say that
netherlands mensen. Oh you praten netherlands for me
Wait, do you say yeah
No
Yes, yes
No, what's yes in dutch?
Pratic
My beloved is a kleptomaniac steals your boy cherry. What you gonna do about it, huh?
Oh, maybe we should have a thief design
Oh
That would be interesting
Um
English is in a language
It's three dialects in a trench coat honestly. This also is beautiful as a wild flower. Yeah
The cherry seed is it stealing if it's a willingly offer?
Boy cherry. I just love that term my boy cherry
My boy cherry. Oh, yeah, your boy cherry
Wait, what are you going to do when a five two scott breaks into your room asking for the boy cherry?
I
Shawnee cut was wanted for
Wanted for 8.06k counts of ink theft. Honestly. I just give up damn straight
Damn straight. I've broken you well, even though I've not even gotten started
And you're right. Actually, I had the right to ace more clubs
Because I've left two girls on red, but no, I have ignorance out of me being a dumb dumb
Sorry, my boy cherry is with another woman. Sorry less. How dare you?
How dare you?
Athernity
What are you doing? I'm curious. What are your thoughts on this return to the office?
So office real estate
Um is a very competitive market
But if there's no value in an office, there can't be astronomical rental prices
Wait, you mean the whole
Market is rigged even for offices as well because people would just say well if offices aren't needed anymore
Why not turn them into more homes?
Oh, wait a minute, but that would lower the demand
Uh the artificial inflated demand by the way, um
And this all come back to office people got a lick of freedom
Um people got a lick of freedom of what it's like to be able to have a decent work balance type thing
And when you give people too much freedom
Uh, they might just get cheeky and revolt and the last thing we want is a cheeky revolt. Um
So if everyone's topic of conversation is
We have to go back to work. That's the people distracted on this conversation for a while 91. I'm jealous. I'm not there yet
Well, scum ass
Proposterous, thank you for the 10 of 30. Um
But yes, if all if imagine right now that every office building
Um that you can think of is lying empty and dormant right now
Because everyone can work from home do it take now. Obviously, that's not how all offices work
But think of the real estate. I would you could probably argue office space may be even outweighs what uh
A living space like no, well, probably not like not actually but you know what I mean
Um, I think you need to log in and out to update the horrors
The high score. Oh, sorry
I read that's horoscope for some reason. I might want you to use that to
In doing the horoscope
Uh, god forbid the peasants revolting as elites can't cycle money between yourself. Well, wasn't there a recent?
post that proved that um
The stock market the only way you can make money in the stock market is by doing daily trading type thing
Because everything is rigged already
Like I'm sorry. I've never trusted the stock market. I don't I look you can be a dumb woman doesn't know what she's talking about
Absolutely. Dumb woman does not know what she's talking about
Something about the stock market concept does not sit right with me
Like it just
I can't make heads. I just something is not right call me bricks and mortar because like at least something
It's physical and attainable
Sun does not sit right with me with the stock market especially
After the what was it game stock shenanigans the people basically went
We see you hedge funds. How about we counteract this and then they locked it down
So wait a minute. We're not allowed to do free trading
The people are not allowed to participate in the trading
Like sorry if that's not evidence enough or doesn't at least have your spider senses going off
Like i'm sorry you're just asking for it
Like I understand like I think the 401k for americans is actually in the stock market
Um instead of like a pension pot. Now, don't get me wrong. Australia, uk all participate in that pension pot
Fucking scamas. Then you get me wrong any private pension fund again. Oh scamas. Then you get me wrong
I get it the world is rigged
But like saws there's no free trade if congress is losing money 401k is a scam stocks is just legal gamble
Like i'm not being funny
um
When that game stop like let's go against the hedge funders like oh, this is abuse of the stock market
No, it's not it's the people
Um having a choice and the the choice was removed. So does that mean everything else is a scamas?
Most likely. I mean, I just can't trust it. I I can I can't I can't go after everything I witnessed during that
Little funny tee he let's go against the hedge funders
uh
like
You can't eat it like they blocked anyone from signing up you couldn't invest in it
So it had they forced it to crash again. They forced it to crash like no, it's not even tin foil
It's documented in real time
Like the the evidence is there
I'm sorry. It's not even tin foil. Sorry. I can't put a tin foil hat on that one
There's something. No, right. There's something fishy. I get on my cuttlefish, but that smells no coming from me because something smells fishy
And it's no this
No, it's not a conspiracy theory. It's evidence
And I'll wait until stormy hears about how the us can take away our freedom of speech during wartime
Oh, don't even get me started on like wars and all that stuff
Don't even get me that eat
How unbelievably sad wars are
um
What after what did they call it it's sheep leading lion
And I feel so sorry for like anyone that's even been roped into the like army and all that
Oh, that's another thing on population control
as well, um
You know who uh army sign-up rates of their lowest they've been because everyone is like so educated now
Who the fuck wants to die for the capitalist cog?
Ne one
Absolutely, ne one. So ne wonder your how your recruitment rates for the army are as low as piss
But when you make people desperate enough for money
Um i.e. getting them born into poverty cycle getting them like down on their luck like having to tolerate all these like
Crappy jobs having to pay these bills that are extortionate and aren't officially inflated and all that
Uh, yeah, you're probably gonna get a few more army sign-ups because people are literally like homeless type shit
They don't have a choice type shit, you know and how unbelievably profitable it is. Oh my god
Like it's just
Oh, that's good enough bread to migrate to australia to join your farm eventually
Enjoy the rain. Oh, no, we're going back to sculling for the farm. Sorry. I'm in australia for business means
Uh, but once the business wraps up
Uh, do not start a business in the uk you get absolutely taxed and you hardly get in and good going for you
Uh, australia though poggers start business in australia
Uh, but thank you so much tiny spiny for the tip. Uh, yes, please do. I am playing with mercy later
Um, scottish farm. Yes scottish farm the army. Oh, if you can join the army, you can retire for 30. No, you cannot. No
um
Like it's just no it's just
It's just no and i can't but i can't believe i'm going absolutely mental
I just feel sorry, but anyway migration to sculling got it. Yeah, it's actually really easy to migrate to sculling
Broly legend
I did it
Not my rant making your hour of work super easy to get by that's hilarious
I'm glad that my little rants can do so
Right, maybe I should focus on cute v-tubers instead of the revolution that i'm secretly planning behind the scenes
What's that? You thought the siren wanted to drown you? No
I wanted to make you
influenced
And then we revolt. No, we don't revolt. We just make a little farm and live a good life. Sorry. It's it's
I don't want to stress you out any more than you have to be a little reefling
So let's let's just have a nice little farm together
We have a beautiful horse that we can enjoy
We have
Food the food is stocked in the pantry. We have all my freeze-dried fruit that last 20 years in case the collapse of society occurs
We have our little bug out bags
um
And during the day we go harvest and chop down trees so we can keep the heating on
And uh, yeah
Let loose the dogs of war. I'm ready my siren queen. Oh, yes. Yes, of course the farm. Yes. Yes
like yes
Valor is a company of peace the rev one message the revolution begins here the next message
We are reefling valor is a company of peace. Yes
The revolution section will not be live stream. No
It will not the revolution
It started all because I wasn't allowed to
clap my
Do clapping ASMR without my hands
Smile
That's that was the final straw that broke the camel's back
Making a little farm under
Capitalism is considered insurgents, but don't worry. We already have to fight for the cause
Do you guys did you guys ever read pig farm?
um
It was about how
It's really like it's really depressing and dystopian
But it was about how the people like seized the means of productions and worked for themselves and it was bliss
Now say it again for the people in the back strong. Oh
Bless the shimei. Thank you for the 20
Look, I'm only allowed to go on a little tinfoil rant for like maybe five minutes at a time
And then I'm not allowed to do it any further
um
But okay, so animal farm long and short
Instead of that. It's very fantasy based. So instead or well fantasy based
The animals on the farm revolt against the farmer and then they run the farm
But lo and behold
Someone cannot help themselves to just start making ranks and be a higher level and get special treatment and
um
The end of the book basically goes
um, the higher animals
um, we're no different than the men that once
um, like uh
You know ruled them as like a thingy. It just it's so depressing, but I love depressing endings. I'm sorry
1984 had my head like I was in a vice reading that book
I could not get away spoilers mate. The book's been out for how long
Is is big george orwell still with us? No, I don't even think orwell is still breathing unfortunately because he
is an old man
Is orwell still breathing?
Yeah, 1984 had me in a vice grip orwell has passed. Yes, I do believe the gentleman has passed um
and like
It's just crazy the comparisons
Especially actually, you know what one of the biggest hints should be if any book gets subdued publicly at any point in any country
Especially any book that gets subdued in like russia for example china for example
Pay extra heat to that book
1984 was banned in certain countries
Um, and if you read it, it is mortifying. Um when you start connecting some of the dots now. Don't get me wrong
It's just a book
But at the same time
Reflings at the same time as I make my countless wines
It is more than just a book. What's your favorite dystopian novel?
Oh, I think I'm gonna have to be basic and say 1984 like I was
Hooked on that book when I started it. I didn't know what I was getting myself into. I did read fahrenheit
I enjoyed it. I fahrenheit. I get it. I'm I believe in it. I do get I do get um
Stay away
Uh
I have to say 1984 was a warning news as the blueprint
Yes, like I don't want to get too crazy on you. It's like I know I'm a wee bit crazy
But I didn't want to get too crazy. Like I you know, I'm still memeing away on ASMR and that like then I get too
Don't get scared to me. I promise. I'm not gonna uh
You know hypnotize you so we take down black rock
um
But yes, uh 1984 was published in 1949 an animal form with 1945. Yes, it's quite
scary the contrast
Uh that or the um similarities that you can pull from a book
from
X many years ago. Um and then
you know
You know, you know, you know
It's stroney getting crazy as hot though
Stroney, have you read pendulum? I have not read full cults pendulum. I don't have time to read books
I'm trying to get through the handmaiden's tale because I see it referenced everywhere and I'm like, what's this book even about?
I've only got a few chapters in but I don't have time to read books. It's so annoying unless like we play an audio book together
whilst I do rinse game
Leveling up in a past life. I was so close to buy a farm in honor of some radishes
Unfortunately, I lost my bid but I'm still aiming for the dream wait for really
We're gonna get a farm or you need to make sure it's not too unmanageable though farms can get a hand quick
Pentium. Thank you for the tip
Frickin stroney me to chat. I mean sometimes are you allowed to do that?
um
Who would have thought the anti capitals revolution would be led by an anime girl literally
I'm uh, uh, definitely need to give needy streamer
I watched the god ending on needy streamer
But she was like we need to take down 10 percent of the population wrong. We need to take down
Unless that 10 percent of the population
No, there's no way it's 10 percent. It's like 0.1 percent that pulls all the strings
Must be
It cannot be it cannot be that higher percentage of 10 percent. All right and needy streamer
She was like, yeah, let's just call 10 percent of the population is like, oh sit down there. I'm not sure I can get behind that one
Uh 10 percent would take out a lot percent anything
wink wink
It's 1 percent. It's the one but is it really that high? I don't think
For those who pull the strings. I feel like one percent is so high and in an eight billion population
Or do you mean it's the one percent?
Ah, okay. Okay. I understand. Sorry. Uh, yes
you know
See if she came out with that rhetoric, I would be giggling in my seat. No, I do not actually believe we should be
Um
Tally whacking people at will. No, that's absolutely not what I'm saying. Relax reeflings. We're not that serious about it
It's just um, it's a very how do you treat the symptoms of a disease that does not want to be cured and will do everything
And it's will not to be cured and actually does everything in its will to get sicker and sicker
and that's why 1984 was actually so, um
Shawnee making wines with the grapes of wrath honestly, um
Um
Shawnee if you stop at pull the strings
It just goes to their friend who are willing to take over got cleared the entire
Hedge growth not a branch. Oh steady. You can't be talking to me like that reefling. You'll turn me on
Stop um
Yes, what do you do about a patient that wants to get sicker and sicker and lets themselves get sicker and sicker
The thing about 1984
was
the people
outnumber
The bigger uppers if you will buy an extortionate amount
And the book basically was like the uprise is coming the uprise is coming the uprise is coming
But the uprise never came because they dealt with it as problems occurred
Obviously now that was very think police stop police. There is a game called we happy few
I feel like if I ever booted up the game we happy few
I would need to shove that tinfoil hat on before the stream even started because I don't know what to expect from it
But from what of herge
it is
kind of like that
Gotta get all the heads off of hydra. I wish all the string pullers are very
Adri chrome shortage
Adrena chrome source
I don't even know what that one is instant heart attack
Like if the death note was like a thing honestly
Honestly, I wonder like just oh no, they had a heart attack because they're old. Oh no
We Flynn you can't say that
She lacks critical information. I actually do for once we well always let's be honest
We have few gameplay mids, but the story is so the gameplay is bad, but the story is good curious
Curious, we might give it a shot. How what does if you type in we happy few how long play time?
What does it say? How many hours does it say?
Stroney, have you heard the oracle of dead delphi? I have not I have not I apologize sad
We had so we happy few so buggy. It had such a good premise though
Actually, I might play a ridiculous game with you. It's an orwell game or well inspired game
It's a tech space game. I might get mercy on it if I'm allowed
Because I know she likes kind of clicker games that don't
Because of our emotion sickness and all that. I might get merch you to play out and be a
Are you squiddling me right now?
Love your ranch stroney. They're so fun. They are so isn't it adorable when anime girls get heated about capitalism
Thank you so much for the tip a glitter
Shit a pot, but we're 80. We're 80
We are 80
That's fun. We can cook sharks if I so desired level 80
There's an orwell game called orwell. Oh, that's the name of the game. You're right. That is the name of the game
You can cook burn sharks. Yeah, I'm not gonna burn the sharks
How long are you streaming today? It's not that long today. Um
I think are we redirecting into sheebie or is a is a zura coming on?
I might be able to push tazura
Uh, she comes on at 11 my time. Does a zura come on? I don't know. Let me tape up a zura duly
A zura duly, are you coming on today? You are coming on my
Is she not a nightmare?
Wait, she's supposed to do little nightmares at 10 a.m
She says she's doing little night nightmares, but I don't see the stream. Is she not put up a thing?
Is she not putting up her her wee lobbies?
If if uh, we will redirect into a zura's
um
Little nightmares in t-minus four hours and 30 minutes. We're gonna do wine for four hours 30 minutes
She be she be starts. Oh, she's starting a bit later. That's fine. Um
I am not going to redirect into emmers out of
Um
Respect because she's doing a collab with an outside person. I'm actually not familiar with them. So I should I should get to know
I'm I'm trying to I'm trying to like have mental capacity to be like, oh, is that friend of
Thingy's right. Okay, right. This is their details. Like this is their design. This is how they sound like type thing
Well, like I'm trying to give a mental note
So like the girl it's like I know about the girl's friends and you know, um, and they're all having a good time, which is good
Um the veal or a tentacle spreading. She hasn't put the weight in room up Danny to put it up for her
Uh, hold on. I'm gonna see if I can get her thumbnail and put it up. Oh no, I can't on this freaking computer gosh darn it
Oh
I don't have access to her thumbnails either
Ah
Azura
I can't put Azura's chat up for her either
Unless I unless I go and make a cup of tea
I can go put up Azura's weight in room for her
I mean, I assume she's okay. She's just forgotten to put everything up. Has she been putting them up like on the day of
Because you're supposed to she was supposed to put full week up
Um, like the management like makes all the thumbnails and that for the girls
So all they have to do is put the room up
Try to make it as least stressful as possible. Yeah, she be is playing inscription today
Never gonna get a massive wine xp draw. Oh, I mean we popped on a we popped on 79 as well
Like it's not I'm just getting distracted. Okay. I'm not gonna be
She was very sleepy yesterday to be honest. Okay. Okay. Um
Right she be doing inscription. I think Azura normally puts the week but the past few days should be a little rough
We finally figured out what a fucking pc problem was thank god because spent a pretty penny on that pc. Um
Ah
But it's still not resolved, but we know what the problem is at least or I think
I think maybe I might be resolved soon again
But it means um her streams will no longer cut off in the middle of the stream where she disappears for a couple of minutes
Once she fixes the problem thank yad
Um, I don't want to embarrass her by saying what the problem was
But dear lord Azura
You're playing with fire
Yeah, and she doesn't sleep well well. Have you ever watched friendly jordies?
Yes, I watched his video where the politician
Uh did a pipe bomb in his house
And he sent one of his goons to put a pipe bomb in front of his house and burn it down
Uh, and thank god he was on tour because that's an ambassador
I
Did she watch naughty stuff on the side what?
No, she didn't no, um
If she's I don't know if she's comfortable with me saying it because um, it's not like mean or anything
Um
Hold on hold on I might actually have my uber market
Hold on I might have my uber market little symbol
Hold on a minute
Hold on is it a discord emoji?
Nope, that's just straight up uber markets emojis. That's not my twitch remote. Is it a twitch thing?
Ah
20 a1
Wait, I'm trying to do too many things at once. I think I have it. Oh my god. I'm gonna I'm about to unlock being a professional streamer
Oh my gosh. I'm about to unlock being a professional streamer. Is it what is it? Is it an image?
I don't know if it's an image. It would market promo
I don't know if it's an image or not and the computer's gonna see it or not or
Oh my god, wait, does it not see it?
Oh my god, check me out professional strummer. Can you guys even read that? I feel like it's so tiny
Oh
My yeah, I'm such a professional streamer. Oh, I need to put it behind me though
Oh my what's that? I have uber market merchandise and I get to keep a hundred percent of the profits. Oh my god
Can you even read the thing?
I don't even think you can read make it a bit bigger
Yeah, I can't even fucking read it the tape. I know the text is so small. Wait. How did the girls have on display then?
Even market
Uh, I've got my hoodie and my key chains on the way. I'm so happy
And then I can do my little hand cam stream. Well, it's just gonna have to be tiny and down there. I know you can't read it. Um
I might edit that so it just says merch
Oh my god, I can see it. Yeah, because that make it massive in the middle of the screen
Yeah, you want me to impede the gameplay with it? Sure
um
I can only read merch. Yeah, I think I'll I'll edit it so it only says merch
Because that's the uwu. I think people are starting to recognize uwu market
It's pretty hand-in-hand with v-tubers at this point. They give it edit the text and paint. Oh, no, that's not gonna work
I would have to like craft it into a gif as well
I'm terrible
um
For level 81
We're in the 80s
Yeah, we can recognize the symbol. Yes
I will edit that but oh my gosh, look how professional I am. I actually have like a little merch window
To be like, oh you can you could support my merchandise
You can wear the hoodie that I'm wearing
Well, not right now because I don't have my hoodie yet, but we can wear the same design together
Yeah, no, we can't sacrifice 100% high octane high quality. Captivating gameplay exactly
Next level you can cook turtles. I don't think I want to cook a turtle. That's not very nice
I would assume people know how to look in the description at this point. Yes. Oh my god
I never say this
Please like and subscribe if you're enjoying the content
Please check out the links in the description below if you are interested in merchandise
Please check out twitter if you want to see me tweet once a week because I hate twitter and I hardly use the damn thing
Actually, how's my little tweet doing?
Wait my when I when I obviously baited youtube. I got them in 4k
Let's see my tweet. I'm shocked. I'm not oh, it's that 200 likes check me out 200 likes on my cheeky tweet
I'm no shocked
Oh
11k. Whoopsies. Sorry. I keep popping because I'm getting distracted
But yes, I believe Azura goes up in roughly t-minus 4 hours. So I think we will get a quick snacky break
um
and uh
At copa tea
And then we will continue our grind and redirect into Azura because I hardly get to redirect into
I always like redirect into mercy because a steamer all over everyone
But before anything, you know, it's gonna seem that's the nice
Bruv
I got shit to do during the day. Okay. I have to go see my chinese auntie during the day
Okay, I need to go ask her her businesses. I was asking about his business and she said good and she asked me how business I said good
I haven't seen my multigranny
Uh, unfortunately, I don't really go at lunchtime
But if I see my multigranny again, I'll tell you is um
But she multigranny was so nice. She was like giving me all these compliments
I'm like, I didn't even kenya and you're my granny like I'm sauce, but I don't make the rules
You're just my grand right now. So I was
I'm just adding all the grands and aunties your aunt is chinese. No
I have I go to uh like a a mom and a mom and pa owned chinese shop
Hey stroney, do you watch the scottish games? Not the fit balls. That's we we got pumped five one on the fit ball. That's all I know
um
I go to a mom pa chinese shop, but um
I've like started up a like I guess friendship with the owner. I don't I don't know you want to say it
She my boss lady. She look after me. Um, and we always just like ask each other like, oh, how are you doing?
How's business? How's the shout out to Malta? I shout out to Malta. Um, Malta benny. Um
We're not even ready for Malta granny. Oh my god Malta granny was like giving me all the tea
So Malta granny is like divorced
But her man is like still around and the last I knew
The man wanted to take her on like a lunch date essentially and I was like, you're not getting back one. Are you?
Um, I like what are you feeling it? Um, and she was like, no, no, I wouldn't be but um
It'll be a nice lunch a nice catch up because like they had wanes together in that
She's got like grandchildren and all that. Um, because she was showing me pictures of the wee baby girl. I've already forgotten her name. Oops
um
Stroney goes around just collecting pets and family. I was saying I was like, is it because I look so like
Pitiful like so you can apply your pity to me like super easily
um
And that's why like I'm just able to like strike up conversations of easily
Okay, well malta granny clocked my accent. She was like, where are you from? I was like, oh scotland. Sorry
I'm sorry for being scotch. I do apologize. Um
And like the sushi man as well. He's nice to me. He clocked the accent. Oh, what's going on with you all this all that?
um
Pitiful that's a funny way to spell cute and perfect honestly
but like, um
Yeah, I've only seen her twice but like she completely opened up to me and all that and I'm like
Um, it's really cute
I was like gave her a hug and everything like we give each other a hug when we like say goodbye and that like boss lady
Chinese auntie she's like been giving me hugs and stuff and that like I don't know. Maybe I'm just like
not
I don't know. Maybe
I don't want to sound like a fucking weirdo, but maybe like I just
like
Bring comfort to people naturally and like they feel comfortable enough like the Vietnamese lady that I tipped
She gave me a hug and she was like come back any time because I tipped her and all that
Like I think maybe I just exude like that kind of hang in folk where they're like, I just feel so comfortable around you
And I was like, yeah, yeah, that's good. Yeah
Shawnee's very squishable, literally. Um, like because I got Christmas
um
chocolates for chinese auntie
And she was like, oh, thank you so much. Um, and she like gave me wine back and all that and I'm like, oh, thank you
Um
But like she always looks at she feeds me well though
Like I'm not being funny whenever chinese auntie clocks me
She always like fills up the food extra and gives me like extra things away
With friends like these
Squishy that uh that you do it's because you treat people like humans
God we are absolutely waning it up in this place. She's slow. Oh shit. How did you even tail all that?
You've paired. Oh my god. You put it in. Anyone got a spear jar going?
Um
chinese auntie fill it up mommy. Oh
It's literally she feeds me so much and she gives me a discount and she gives me extra food
Like just to look after me
And I'm like, bro. I'm sorry, but everyone's like so lovely
Um
Everyone's so lovely in australia. I've never had one bad interaction. Actually, I tell you I had one bad interaction in australia
Tell jeff over there. Hey, um, I'm sure it was just like a long bad day. Um
But um in the uk when you use your card
It does not ask for a prompt
To take it from your savings account a debit account or something like that
For some reason when you use a card in australia
It gives a prompt and it's like take the money out of these three areas and I'm like, but it's a debit card
It can only come out of one area
And and basically I was holding up the till and um, I asked her I was like, I'm so sorry
But what does this mean like, um, this is just a debit account the money's in the account what one day I hit
Um, and like she did explain it to me with like a big huff and a size type thing
Um, and I was just like, I'm really sorry, but in scotland
We don't have anything like that. You just use your card and then she like can't not pass
I guess it was passive aggressively. She was like, well, you're no in scotland anymore. Are you and I was like, oh, okay, um
But I'm sure it was just a bad day and she was overworked like give people the benefit of the doubt empathy
Get be empathetic. Exactly. Oh my god. I wanted to do an empathy stream
Empathy this is a perfect example. Someone made a snarky remark towards me
How can we be empathetic to someone that may have said something that was a bit of a negative experience?
To show empathy we think to ourselves. Well, this person's working odds are minimum wage. They're exhausted
They most likely have a family issues going on behind the scenes. They've probably not been well rested
Um, so their filter to be polite had gone for that moment
If only for a moment we give someone the benefit of the doubt and we practice empathy. Whoa, just like that
Cut their brake tyres
Steady on maybe that's not rather empathetic of you, but we will try our best to be more empathetic to situations like this
um
Shout out to chinese aunties
There's this old chinese woman that owns her shop down the road and work and she brings me free stuff whenever I have a bad day
Literally chinese aunties look after you so selflessly and she works so hard. Like I absolutely adore my auntie. Um
Like we're on a first name basis and everything and I don't know when our birthday is and all that but I should maybe ask
I can get her something nice
Talking about that if you ever go to a convention in real life, would you be comfortable hugging the refunds? Oh my god? Yeah
I'm sorry. I don't know why people would be
Uncomfortable. I mean, I guess I'm just maybe I'm naive. Let me be naive. I'm sorry, but
Let me be naive. Let me enjoy
Reflings at a convention. Let me hump them. That's all I'm saying. I'll have security. I'll handle
I'll hire the security guard. So if things get out of hand, I'll be like no, no, but I'm gonna be honest
Um, I did get a bit of feedback where folk were like I'd be too
I'd be too scared to like look her in the eyes if you're too scared to look me in the eyes
I feel like my voice is going to be like a thum in Skyrim and if I say it right back off
Like everyone's gonna be like whoo because you're not used to me being like
Like expressing negative emotions that you need to back off right now. I'm being serious
Like I feel like everyone would be like, oh
Did anyone a deal with strong a like that?
um
I heard all of them. Well, I don't know what convention we could possibly go to but um
I contact a little bit of nave. He goes a long way. Oh my girl
Well, all of my girlfriends have been long distance, which means I've always been at risk of organ traffic
Stereo and let's like keep our organs intact
As much as living with one kidney is possible. It does put down your function down a little bit. Oh, sorry
Um
Yes yell at me more sexy squash woman
I don't even know about being scared but physical contact with a bunch of strangers seems like an easy way it gets like
I mean I'd have hand sanitizer with me as long as no one's like
I bet you someone would take it a contest being like this streamer hates the reeflings because she has hand sanitizer
It's like no motherfucker. I want to stream when I get back home
I want to stream
I don't want to be sick
So I need to use hand sanitizer whilst we're all touching each other not like that
When we hold hands and stuff and like do high fives and hugs or whatever
Oh my god, should for like the severely tism should I get a little chart for you so you can point on the chart?
What interaction you want from me?
So the first one's like a high five
The second one is hold your hand. The third one is a hug and then the fourth one is me sitting on you
Should I do that? So for those of you who struggle to speak
To whammy don't worry. I got you covered. I'm one of the bros for one and two
I've got a little pictorial chart so you just point to what interaction you want nice and simple
See you don't even have to talk if you're too shy that you can't get words out or you have a starter
I got you covered man
Oh, it'd be a big poster board for what we're wanting
I'd bring a sign saying strongy. Please great me bruv. I think they'd take that sign off you
I'm pretty sure conventions take signs off of people
Um, which I didn't know about they also take away like fake weaponry if it doesn't have the orange tip on the weapon
um
Yeah points at high five and nods like oh, yeah
Secret hidden minis like no, no
Uh, I don't think we're getting the ASMR booth rip rip and piss you shan't be missed
Oh my god, I'm gonna have to get nice and fit for the the convention me and I work on my glutes make them even bigger for you
Different con different rules. Ah, okay. Okay. Okay. Mommy is so thoughtful. Hmm
I know some people seem to like struggle with whammy, but like didn't struggle with me like then yeah
You didn't have to worry about me me. Uh, should you I'm as brain dead as you are if anything
I'm actually more brain dead. You're smarter than me. So you really shouldn't have to be worried
Uh
If I met you in real life, I'd go feel scott's and only you'd understand might probably
No, the refland you guys have been learning my scottish accent very well
You guys have been getting used to
um
Like I was eating my burger and someone pointed out I said canny passively like I've I don't know if you've noticed
I've slowly been slipping into using a tiny bit more scottish slang
Just because uh, you guys are getting used to it. So I don't really feel forced to like
I don't know
Annunciate my words more like I've been a bit more mumbly in recent streams because that's kind of where I naturally lie
um
Line-up reflings mean to help mommy with her squats, honestly
I'm fairly expecting my boss to ask me. What is what's for that scottish accent a refling message with that?
They were like
They were working and they spoke at their work
um, and uh
basically
um
Long story short
Uh, they've been developing an accent because they've been like mimicking because you mimic what you hear
It's very natural to mimic what you hear. It's completely natural. Don't ever be embarrassed
and
Passport bros like that. What's a passport bro?
Like that accent passport bros like that accent
I'm so sorry. I don't know what that terminology is. Are you teaching me something new refling?
A passport bro
I've been using me haps unironically. Yes, it's happening
me haps
Would you kindly a passport bro is a person that marries women from overseas?
A passport was when you move to a foreign country and find a more traditional way
She doesn't know a passport bro passport where men who look for women overseas. Oh
Like 90 day fiance as a retail worker one of my most memorable moments was when some lady apologized for her friends
Ridiculously insulting attitude when she didn't like my answer
Thank you to anyone with even a minuscule amount of empathy. Oh, I know I'm a miss. Thank you for the tip
I'm sorry. You had to experience that bra
I'm literally always on the side of like the fucking retail worker. I'm
Maybe because you know I worked as a waitress. Um, but like it's freaking terrible like with some of the stuff you have to go through
I am very lucky. I was in a tourist cafe
Which meant I had a lot of um people who were you know, having a good time. Um,
Didn't really have any issues. I was just looking for the authentic like Scottish experience type thing
With the the food on the menu and that so there really was no issues. Um
I actually can hardly think of one really bad experience. I had
Essentially an American Karen, but it honestly wasn't that bad. So in American table culture
the
waitresses I believe
Make money via tips so they want to serve as much tables as possible to make as much tips as possible
So I think once you're finished eating they give you the bill and spank your butt and out you go in the UK
um, if you're a patron, um, it is very common just to sit and enjoy
Your lovely jubbly meal. Um, you can sit and digest for a little bit and continue the conversation with your party members
Um, unfortunately, we did have a an American family come in
peak peak tourist season, uh, no reservation had uh walked on by and came on in and
We very we I say we because um, I had to get boss man in on it
We very politely had to explain bro. We are fully booked. Uh, we have tables out the wazoo
Um, if you just take a left down the street, you will find tons of cafes that have much bigger capacity type thing
Um, I'd love to debate strongy. Good because I'd like to master debate you. Thank you. Thank you
Yes, um and
basically
She in front of guests
It's pointed at them pointed at guests at table and said their plates are empty. We want a seat there
And I was like, oh
This is a culture clash because one that's highly inappropriate and two that is highly inappropriate and three that's highly inappropriate
Um, and basically obviously we're like, yeah, we don't have capacity like off your pop
And um, and she went somewhere else that was like for in terms of Karen's story. Yeah
I really ain't that bad. I really ain't that bad
This is why I'm going to be late for work tomorrow despite working from home
Wait, do you need to go to sleep? If anyone needs to go to sleep, please rest well
I believe she be and eme are about to go live eme is doing a wonderful wonderful collab with someone
Unfortunately, I forgot the name on please apologies. Um, and she be is going live with inscription
Um, a little card based her base
Thinking my barber
There was that fort folk out. I want to eat it was very like, oh, this is definitely a culture clash because that is like you cannot do that
and
You cannot be pointing around at people's empty plates demanding that we kick them out in quotation marks
So you can get a seat. Yeah, I don't want like that. She be has delayed until a later time
That is not my time zone. So that is
Emme isn't live for another two hours. She be is delayed. Okay. There are harem
Harem on standby harem. Don't worry. You don't have to be on copium for long. It's one hour. She's asking for one hour. Okay
Once she be goes live, I'll take a break question mark and I'll go get a tea question mark and some snacks question mark
um
Yeah, that sounds rude doing that is the fastest way to get thrown out of an establishment in the cobs called
Thankfully, I have never ever been in a situation where like police had to get involved
um, the weirdest situation
Doing a tango or having a square
the weirdest situation ever was
um
so
um a member of staff overheard this table
Talking to amongst themselves that they were going to skip on paying the bill
Like they were going to do a runner. I think it's called dine and dash as the terminology
Doesn't listen to her huff that copium. It's going to be a one hour. You can hold on for one hour
Or here. I'm sorry. You can hold on for one hour here
You've held on for longer for she be okay. Um
Uh, basically overheard someone do a dine and dash. So then someone had to fucking guard the door
Um in order to prevent them from doing that and paying and they looked so sheepish
Like when they were paying they looked so scared
So I think they genuinely were going to do it. They were just idiots and said the crime part out loud for some reason
Whoa that voice
Uh, yeah, don't don't ever say your crime out loud for some reason. I don't know why people think that's okay
Um
Yes, sorry, I got just I'm I'm reading the replies on my my little mean uh
My little mean post on twitter and I'm giggling away on my head
I am I'm so funny. I'm so humorous sometimes
Boss mom stroney prepares everyone for the girls looks like mommy you should play bread and fred for a collab. What the heck is bread and fred?
Unless your name's fred. I ain't getting bread in this scenario
What's bread and fred? Is it like a joe? Must be a joe
Don't say it alone. Don't record it
I suck on blue
We're officially on
53,000
Wines surely this is not going to get tedious. Um next week. We are doing uh endurance runescape
We are doing the full john wick series in order to save my voice
um
because
Yeah, we're basically i'm gonna mute the game and you're just gonna hear my mouse and my reaction to the movie um
Because i'm needing i'm needing a bit of a break
But i'm needing to make progress towards cooking because we've not made the best amount of progress we're on the 21st
Oh, I should have an audio coming out. What today?
I have an audio coming out tomorrow on patreon
I can't remember the plot though. Oh
but
I
Can't is it is it blow bob?
I don't know what my plot is tomorrow
I forgot I forgot I can't remember. Um, we are going to write my fourth script together next week
Um, which is a honey tea plot, uh, honey ink tea plot
Yeah, we get to do it together. Um, so I'll I'll say what you want me to say
Yeah, we're gonna write it together in a member stream
Speaking of audios alt twitter audio is possibly my favorite thing right now feels good man feels good
I go so freaking shy. I was so annoyed. Literally. I remember looking over the
I actually recorded it in obs which was dangerous. I shouldn't have but I did anyway
Um, and I remember looking at the timer and it was like two minutes and 11 seconds and I was like
Bro the allegations that I'm a quick shot. This is getting a bit too much now. Um
I was like, oh, right. Okay. I'll keep going but then ended up getting shy
Which artificially extended the time feels good, man. So now I did a normal amount
I'm so normal I'm a normal
There are no allegations
But what about the noises
In the background. Oh, no, that's my chair. I did it in my chair. This one right here that I'm sitting in right now
That's what all the squeaking and all that was because I had both my legs up on the desk
That's what all the squeaking was
my wee my wee gamer chair
I did it right here
Right here is where I did it
I finished my stream
I got my figurine
Uh looked up some absolutely devious plots and went to them
Is there proof on the chair? No, there's not proof on the chair
Uh
Although possibly there could have been now that I think about
But never use the pc that someone lives on at least not in keyboard and mouse
Yeah, you do not want to be touching anything of mine
I was actually gonna do a washing my keyboard asmr type thing because it's like absolutely filled with gunk
Washing my keyboard cleaning my keyboard asmr
How much for the chair
No, you're not getting this chair. It's had everything on it swear ink
most probably traces of
Uh
Um, I wouldn't be surprised because I like uh, just I never wear clothes. I'm wearing clothes because it's cold today, but
I really struggle
Why are you selling it to us? I'm not selling it. I'm keep it. I need a chair to sit on to stream on
Sorry, we already want the tree. You don't actually need to sell. Oh, should I bring it to the convention? Someone can just wheel it away
Yeah, no, that's gonna happen
Hi guys, everyone sniffing the seat
50 cents to smith to sniff my chair
my gamer chair
You have us though. Oh
We'll be the chair. Okay. Okay. Maybe some of you guys are into chair stuff more than I thought
Hey, sorry. What is it furniture furniture? Is that furniture your bank?
Any furniture your bankers
You're naughty naughty boys, right
Stranny you can sell the seat and just cut it into a small piece and sell it. Uh
Put on a wee keychain
I am a throne feels good. Yeah, sorry
What was that about chairs my face? Oh, okay. I get that I get that
Wow, we have 800 wine brewing. This is like the longest I've ever gone
I think I don't know what my biggest exp pop was or what it can go to but it looks like we're at 900
Unformented wine right now
Tag you're it tag you're it boom boom boom. We're at a
Eight eight two. I don't know what that is. Did you get that chair oil?
Now it's still squeaky chair
I sent you some late reading on marshmallow. Oh, I actually no check marshmallow yet
Um, I cannot check marshmallow for the tame being
Oh, no
Oh, no, what does that mean sonic? I'm sorry. I'm just gonna have to be cryptic
To have to have access to the marshmallow. Oh, no. Oh, no, I have to be cryptic. Oh, no
Anyway, about it. It's not a big deal
Um
But yes, again, thank you to any youtube clippers
You are making my job so much easier because I need to send clips on to johnny forgot her pass for the end along
Yeah
Um, I will right so she be comes up in 46 minutes
We'll get a break. I'll get a snack. I actually don't need to pee because I'm so severely dehydrated right now
Yep, eighties what it is
What's the model of your keyboard? I'm so sorry. It just says corsair. I don't actually know what it is
It might be the Australian version. I didn't know that
British keyboards and Australian keyboards are different because there's a key binding that's in a different place or location
And I'm like, why why is it not universal?
So I might have an Australian corsair keyboard. Um, it lights up. That's all I know. I'm trying to look for a label on it
Oh, wait, I can turn it over. Hold on. I'm turning my keyboard over right now
Uh, hold on. I want to make sure I don't accidentally
De-wine myself, which is not what we're wanting to do
Hold on the keyboard has been turned over. I'm looking at spare bottom
the keyboard says
Corsair k70 rgb mk2 mechanical gaming keyboard. Is that what you wanted? Did I do it right?
That's surely what you wanted, right? That's surely what you needed the information you seek
Well
Uh, it does have a uk. Wait, is this a british keyboard or not?
Identify yourself. Are you a british keyboard? Did I bring you?
You british
It says uk in canada
It says uk and c8. Okay. I think this is a british version of the corsair
Corsair is shit
Okay, what do you want me to cry about it?
What was that? How is it bad? Am I being pepega? Why is it bad? It does what I need it to do
You don't know you just don't like it
Oh, did a mod tickle your message?
Get right
You can tell it's british if the keys are cr-
A riflin
Riflin that's too funny. I can't even laugh at that
I
Riflin
That's terrible
Now you're fine. Well, I was the me that did it. I was the me that did that didn't mean I didn't remove your message
The british teeth humor and sham will stop because I've got messed up teeth. The allegations aren't looking good for me
I can't believe it. I can't believe I wasn't sponding with veneers attached
Um, oh, we should do the veneer ramble one day
When I say we should do the veneer rant one day, do I mean should I do it right now?
What happens if we go on the root canal rant? Oh
But wait, but I'm british so I'm not sure I can start on anyone's teeth to be honest
I'm british you have no mercy. My favorite one is the fish
It's like a fish and it goes well at least our schools and then that's the meme. It just cuts off
There's nothing else to the meme. It's just like a fish. We're really messed up teeth and it goes well at least our schools
Um, I wonder if I can find it and put it on the screen. Oh, I don't think I have enough time to
Do my way. Oh god. I've already had a root canal
Oh
So root canal is has a very high success rate of failing
And if your tooth is at the point root canal is advised
You're probably better just getting it removed to be honest
um
I think I didn't understand anything the peeler allegation. Oh my god, merci freaking joined in the peeler allegations
I'm now giving shift the ice to zura because if a zura does it it's on me next
And I'm like, oh no
So it's on a zura the ball is in a zura's court
If a zura does it
Then unfortunately, I will not hold up the allegation. No, I will hold up the allegations and do my part
The last literally think of it like a rat a baton rally race. I think she be was first and then it went emmy
Then it went icy then now it's mercy
So the baton is is the baton has been extended to a zura
Will she pick up will she grab the baton and run to me is the question because this rally race is getting intense
It's getting a bit. I'm getting nervous. This rally race looks like it might actually we might actually win
Strongly needs soon. Well, if we were gonna do it, I was I was thinking I would purposefully
Hydrate as much as possible and like hold it in while we do a stream type thing and then afterwards
all of it
Every last drop in 4k
I mean, I could even get my 3d o over that's how
Um, like because I have a task cam that feeds into the 3d o so I can you know if you wanted to hear it
By neural I could like flip the mic around was them doing it. Why not?
I
Had to get oh, I can read that. Sorry. Sorry. Sorry to go on. I don't know what you said, but it's already gone
Huh, please don't give in the thought of you joining in on it is not good for my mental health
Wait, are women not allowed to pee?
Am I going crazy?
Does that make me
Yeah, I think you're crazy. I actually don't know the
I remember when I remember I remember when a reflin traded me
And he got really shot what
A reflin. I don't need any runescape money though. I have 22 million. I'll take it though. Don't get me wrong
I'll take it though, but refling
Oh, you're such a sugar daddy reflin. What the heck 82. Let's go
level 82
I remember when
Reflin actual sugar. Oh my god. You bowed you gave me money and bowed
Literally gave gives me money bows doesn't say anything else. What a child honestly. Oh, sorry. I need to put it all away
Not just some of it
I remember when
I remember when I
That's the work though
Yes, my goal was to get to 85. I think in the stream
Um, we do have time. I think we have time to get to 85
in game fendom
Someone was like, are you gonna do fendom?
Oh
That would literally do what emmy did. That's her injury. Oh was it. Thank you for a broly legend. Thank you for the five
I remember when wait, are you giving me are you giving me more?
Is that new? Oh, you are giving me more. Why do you want to give me more? Hold on
I need clear some inventory via waning in order to do it. That stream was legendary
Well, she sent me a clip. She wanted highlight of it and it was one of you guys absolutely terrorizing her
Wait, why are you giving me more money? You've already given me some. I mean, I'll take it though, but
Are you sure?
Thank you
What the heck look at my bank stack
Literally, sorry whenever folks say women don't have it easier
I'll just have 25 million in the bank. I have all the wines I need to get to 99 and you're telling me women don't have it easier
Lamal
Don't have it easier by the way
Thank you very oh, I've just taken out. Oh
Wait more you're joking
You're joking
No, no, I'm not accepting that. I am not accepting that. I don't care. I am not accepting that
No, you're not giving me 2 billion in game currency. I do not accept that's outrageous
That is outrageous. You're not giving me 2 billion in game currency
Value loss. Holy crap
2 billion
2 billion that's an oiler
What is your you've got construction 99. Are you laughing? Oh, no. Are you sad because I rejected your stats
2 billion. How long did that take you to even get? Eat the rich. Yeah, you're getting eaten out first bend over
2 million gp
Do you do like the arena gamble possibly?
Stroney's gonna single-handedly crash the runescape economy. I should
But now don't don't get me wrong. I love a cheeky bribe here and there 2 billion is outrageous
It's a grievous amount of uh currency that I will never burn through
So I don't want to yank it gold digger would be an understatement
um
I don't know at that point. It's like a planet made of gold
Extraction that's not even gold digging. That's insane
Per refling got rejected, but not in a bad way. Just in a do not give me that kind of money because I would never utilize it
Kind of way. There's no I wouldn't even know what to do with that
Fletching 99 question mark like that's probably it
Shawnee if you ever play Final Fantasy, I'll pay your sum. I don't know what Final Fantasy is about. I'm so sorry
It's a as right. Don't be mad when I say this out loud. Is it like World of Warcraft or am I mistaken?
Night name prayer and construction would be like one fourth of that
Uh, wouldn't 99 prayer be you guys running dragon bones to me?
Is that not how you're supposed to do it?
Is that not how night name prayer works in Rinscape that you guys run dragon bones to me to the altar?
And we and whoever perishes with it. We just accept it
Shawnee join the peeler. I only need you and Azura. Then my collection will be complete
The balls in Azura's court. I'm not kicking that ball
I'm not kicking that ball
Um
It is in Azura's court
I will be the finishing seal. I will break the last seal if you will because
Why I'm in love to go on about how don't break seal. Don't break seal
It's different from World of Warcraft and everywhere. Okay. It's a tap targeted MMO like well, but it's about
Eh, I think it's a large Azura's last pick. Oh, did you see Azura's picture? Oh my god
It was so good
How did I get so lucky with all these porters?
Um
Yeah, if you haven't seen Azura's picture, uh, it's on our all-town of twitter right now. You're welcome to check it out
Um, it's fantastic
Absolutely. It's delicious
um
Yeah, she bought thigh highs, but they hardly go up to her thighs. So
she uh, really uh the
It's really fit in the lore to be honest because Azura is really tall
Wait, did you see Aisy's most recent picture?
Does any of you be concerned?
Aisy schnupos
I can spell her name. Oh, she's completely shadowbound for me lucky me
Psytastic
As if you can't see Aisy, I can literally see her name right there
Hold on video game. We are trying to look up important factors
Wait, is it banned? Can't be
There's Emmy's alternative right there
Hello, there's Aisy's regular account
Why can't I not see it? It's just Aisy
Aisy schnupos
This account doesn't exist. What is she called schnupos?
Oh, because we couldn't fit her full name in the url
Okay, that makes
Okay, let's go. Uh, what's this picture that's going on here?
I didn't know she posted that. I'm gonna need a five minute break
I didn't know she posted that
Softum-tum
She got a heart attack
I just got banned from ranked legal legends for calling actual cheaters out in the game lmao
Wait, is that an ice cube over her?
Her her her marshmallows out
Her marshmallow is out. She had to use an ice cube to cover it
Yeah, damn, Aisy
Aren't you glad that violor does not run the girls accounts?
Admit it. Admit it. Say I cooked right now. Aren't you glad that we do not run the accounts or and we just let the girls
Do what they want. Admit it. The girls do not need to come to us for nothing
Say thank you
Oh, you're trading me. Oh, is this new? Oh, it is new. Sorry
Say thank you strong kids. Yes. Yes. See the girls can do it
And the allegations that are gonkes
What is this
I didn't even know what you're giving me. What is it platinum token? Uh, what does it do?
We're just planning on talking
One million coins it's coins
Use on the bank, but it's one K token. What?
I have not seen this
I mean, I think I have enough money refilling though, but thank you though. Use it on the bank
I'm sure bank banker
Deposit
Let's draw placeholder edit
It's so people can hold more than
Sorry, I'm papaga and I'm not familiar with your use it on the banker banker. Oh like like select banker
exchange your platinum tokens for coins
Oh
That's oh wait, so there's like a maximum bank amount you can have do you want your money back?
I or do you want me to put into tokens? Do you want the money back refilling?
You've given me so much money
Uh, I've taken a coin of interest apparently
Now you don't want it
Wow, I didn't even know that was a mechanic
I thought it was all like
Um, god, what's my bank up fucking? Oh my bank of gilinor is 31.9 million now estimated
She
Yeah, it was a hot picture tummy and thighs on debuts where the community would be too borny
Yeah, it turns out the girls kind of
Oh, I don't have access to my other upside of account so I can't even comment on it
Can't interact with it. I'm a mean
I need to show others that I'm I'm not a brand risk smile
kidding
I can't donate in
Life, so I'm giving you here. I think you've given more than enough refund. Don't worry about it. Thank you. Holy crap
Colonel know it'll know in that exact number. Oh colonel know it all
You know Neil
Yeah, there ain't no I don't know what's going on with the word colonel to be honest
um
emise and Maggie
Still can't believe you rejected tube
I was not going to take two billion. I would never even be able to do anything with it. Are you serious?
So honey, you got to think like a capitalist to beat the capitalism
What should we raise funds so we can bribe politicians to put in actual policies that are good for the people?
Whoa, no, you can't say such things
Whoa, should we become billionaires?
But rule the world forget
And we'll destroy billionaires from the inside out. Is that how we should do everything?
And all started with a little are you giving me more money? Right? No more money. No more money after this
Thank you refilling, but no more money. You can't give me anymore. This is getting
This is getting a outrageous amount of money a outrageous amount of money, right? No more money. Thank you
But no more because you're literally draining yourself dry
Unless you know
You're having reactions to this because I know some guys are interested in bindom, but it's not really for me only for evil
Thank you for putting attention on ic's post. Yeah, did we all unanimously type in ic snow in s?
Okay, but use it on the banker like right now
Like right now, uh, did you hear about this? Uh, did you use this?
Boom. Nope. Sorry. Select and then hit the banker
Yes
Okay, and then put it in the bank. Yeah, damn
I'm watching live a smart tv a family
So all of the family are
Does your family speak english?
Please tell me they speak some sort of language so they can't understand
No, I'm adam
Assalamu alaikum yalla
That's the best I got for you. It's the best I got. I'm sorry. I'm so sorry. It's the best I got
I'm so sorry
Um, how to say oh, what is it peace upon the prophet?
Oh, no, that's what that's what assalamu alaikum. Uh, alaikum salam
Assalamu alaikum yallaikum salam
Woo, we are multicultural up in this house. That means peace be upon the prophet and peace be with him
Uh, if I am correct
100% correct. Oh, I'm so multicultural come from a wheel and the scotland and I'm a wee multicultural not for an
Not bad for an
Thank goodness. They cannot speak english. Um, that's all I'm saying
Well, I'm off. Good luck for the skill. Thank you so much for all the monies
Unironically in oil prints in real life and in runescape. Check them out. Check them out. Hey. Hey. Look at that. Look at that
construction cape as well flakes and all that
I don't think we don't know us
We are we welcome reeflings of all cultures. We do funny joe cusfinden mentioned
But I just have to pay my mechanic. So it's less funny mama love mama love
reefling love
our bombis good. Thank you for the tip and
Oh, our car is expensive to fix
You see I did this genius thing called buying a bike. It costs me 300 bucks. I've had it for a while now
I don't have to pay for fuel
Unless you count food as fuel, but that doesn't count at all
um
Uh
Cars are very expensive to fix. Yes cars are very expensive to have someone fix it for you less though
970 dollar belt
No more tipping for a while. Okay. That's a nasty price
That is a very nasty price
Nasty nasty nasty
I used to ride a bike to and from work every day. It was amazing. Then I got COVID and didn't have the breath for it
I got COVID and it messed me up good
Um as much as I would love to talk about the conspiracy series behind COVID. I can
I can
Um, but yeah, COVID absolutely got me in a chokehold. It was um not fun
Um, I was very ill and I was actually considering
Calling the doctor to come out. Well, I don't know if they would call you'd call a doctor out for
COVID because then you could contaminate the doctor
Um
But yeah, oh please don't remember Schumer's on
Um, I had to I don't know if you guys remember this Australia shut down its borders
Um, and the requirement of getting into Australia was being vaccinated. Believe it or not. Do you remember? Um,
No, Vak Djokovic the tennis player he got booted out the country
Um for no being vaccinated
But then it got leaked later whilst the whole country was in shutdown
That these tv stars were coming over to record a movie or something
Whilst like the entire country was in shutdown. So it was like, aye rules for us, but no for you
Classic, I mean the hand in the uk as well. They were was it?
They were hosting like parties and Downing Street whilst they were telling the nation like don't go outside
No, you're not allowed to go visit your past away family member at a funeral type thing. I was like
Talk about rules for you and no for me much
Yeah, I remember that. I don't know. I got it for like one day. You got one day or no
COVID like absolutely decimated me. I was down and out on my arse for about a week
I remember on the worst day
I woke up and I said to myself if I even feel a
Fraction of a worse than I do right now like worse than I do right now
I need to call for help because this isn't right. Like I do not feel right. Classic uk
We weren't allowed more than five kilometers from your house. Yeah, what the heck? I'm like fucking
Classic uk classic Australia
I just noticed someone wanted to trade me. Uh, yeah, I think you missed them. He may he might have been
The sugar daddy rifling. Uh, that was probably gonna gift you a few things, but don't worry about it
Or all my xp pop. Sorry. I'm taking too long. I'm getting too distracted
Um
There
Oh
Love my RuneScape music love my RuneScape music love my reflins love love me one simple ass
Simple ass
That is seven things. I've only had a word. I feel bad. I look to be at the worst time. Oh, I don't worry about it
Here do you want my wine?
Here look, I'll trade you. I'll give you my wine and make it better a little refund here. There you go
Take the wine
Take the wine. Yes, there you go. Take it all
You can't trade this item
Eh
Oh, because it's not fermented
Sorry, shari. It's not fermented
I have to have to ferment the wine. Geez
Oh, it's okay. I mean I can do it now
Ah beef. Oh my god. I'm not Wayne maxing. I'm getting distracted trying to make sure my reflings are all happy
As long as you're happy. I'm happy. That's the main thing
Making half the state orange you got a love peeler. No
As I said the balls on his ears court
I mean, I'll be the last one to um
Oh, he's actually back to give you stuff
Accept it refling
Sugar daddy refling is blessing us all
You're happy feels good man. Yeah
um
Um needing to get these ASMR. Thank you videos up because I'm ticking the
with it now
Um, you know that that video has been taken down the debt is now seven
ASMRs I have collabs I need to add it. Um
Did I have a short stream at all coming up? Oh, that wasn't me. Congrats. You're over level up
Did I even have a short stream coming up or am I fubbering up for the next few days?
I think we might be having um
A few sleepless nights coming up
In order to get oops. Sorry. No, I don't want the herring, but thank you though
What
Even I'm doing old school and then I'm playing. Oh, I actually have an announcement
um
I am not doing the uno collab
She be because um, so originally the club actually didn't even have me in it in the uno collab
Um, she be was originally going to be in it, but her work clashed with it
Um, so I stepped in um because it was supposed to be like kind of a we send off for em
Because she's about to go on holiday
on holiday
um
Because I wanted um, you know embers to feel our love unanimously. Um
So she be is stepping in I am not doing that uno club. So I'm changing the schedule
I do have a member's ASMR stream, but I'm going to change it
um
I am going to play
Baltro
I think we'll do two hours of Baltro and then two hours of member stream ASMR. Um
And then that four hour day will allow me to catch up on all my editing that I'm missing out upon
Um, because yes, she just quit her in real life drop. Not streaming. Oh, did I say it the wrong way around? Sorry
She be quit her in real life job
Not valour
Um, so she be is taking my spot in the uno club. So it is she be mersey emmy
And azura together having fun shenanigans. Um, so please do look forward to that
Um, I will be doing a member's
stream
Which will be redirect remembers ASMR. Oh, did I redirect a hundred of members ASMR?
Um
Decisions decisions. I think I will because I don't think anyone sleeps during my ASMR
Let's be honest. None of us are sleeping during it. Um
I will redirect into them and you guys can watch them. I will then go and catch up on all my editing
and
I'm really really excited for the ASMR stream. I don't even have anything planned for anything special
It always turns into the same thing where we're being really inappropriate with one another, but I don't mind it. I like it
um
Yeah
Very curious, very curious. Take care of the madness running. Actually your ASMR is the only ASMR that puts me out
Is it because my voice is so monotone naturally like
Yeah, you like it. You're like a monotone voice. Oh, you feel so sleepy, don't you?
And sometimes my accent makes me say a funny word
And it's rather humorous, but yet you can't stop listening because it slowly brings you down
And to ever lie
Your eyes riefling your eyes they feel so heavy heavy heavy eyes
But that's okay riefling. It's all gonna be okay. Just relax
No, I'm not gonna put you to sleep right now, but
That is
Yeah, like when you talk like that. Yeah tingle when you talk like that brain
I like when you go between soft spoken and whispering. Hmm
I I'm having a fun time
Collabbing with other creators because I put in the script. Please whisper and then they do soft spoken and I'm like, ah
Plus no cigar. I think I might need to make a little audio tutorial and be like, this is general talking
This is
Soft whispering because you can actually still hear me. It's soft spoken. Sorry soft spoken is when you can still hear that
And the voice okay, and then whispering is when you're actually whispering and there's no grip to your voice because there's not enough
voice
Um
Yeah, I've asked for people like please whisper through the script
So I've recorded my lane's whispering and they've done it soft spoken even though I asked for whisper
I'm like you goofy goober you
yard
The one thing I hated about the ASMR community is that people label stuff ASMR, but it's really audio
Don't
What do you mean?
What my ASMR streams have me laughing because I stuck a stick up my nose and completely break any ASMR aspect of it
What are we talking about? No
Yeah, it's me. It's me that abuses the ASMR tag
Sorry, I'll start naming my stuff not ASMR. Okay
Yeah, it's hilarious and cute. I sent a way to get clipped. I don't know if it's appropriate for if it will turn into a clip, but uh, yeah
At lol, I love the snores the ASMR snores
Peppa pig
No, no, no, that's not what meant. Oh, did I misunderstand? Sorry, my apologies
Most ASMRs put a lot of work into learning not to whisper because it's really bad for your vocal record me on the other hand
fuck them
Tear my vocal chords apart. I will do whatever makes you happy if my my whispering makes you happy
I will whisper
I was fighting millennia
Well, that was happening and it made me
It made the fight impossible you giggling away at yourself ASMR not ASMR essentially. Yes. That's how I'm going to start labeling it
ASMR is just
Shit wasn't time for scrawny honestly. I love a good ASMR meme. Sorry. I do I can't get away from it
I love it. I'm so like I completely understand don't get me wrong
I completely understand why that butt clapping video got taken down, but it was so fun
It was such a funny idea. You know what youtube
a
Five years ago or whatever four years ago three years ago. No, actually all this freaking breathing stuff is recent
YouTube three months ago with a he-hod at that and then all of a sudden there's been the stealth update
Breathing bad women breathing bad
Afternoon strongy house cooking. We're cooking by via fermentation of wine. Um, we are just
um
We're level 82. I did want to become level 85
The reeflings have completely stalked me out the wazoo for all the wine. I'm gonna actually need
I've got Gandalf over here. What's going on? Gandalf the yellow
Check it out. Oh, we got uh, no
Oh, you're pimped out in a different costume
I thought it was a new refund. You tricked me
You tricked me. You look mildly different than before
You must be a whole new person
At first I was a little disappointed at the meme ASMR, but whenever it's an ASMR is ASMR especially from strongy
Oh, I'm sorry. You didn't kind of like it. But I don't know. I just I just I like the non serious stuff, you know
Like literally I have an ear cleaning ASMR and it starts with me going the std clinic is two doors down
And then you come in and it's actually you're getting your ears cleaned like I'm sorry. I love a little tea heat
I love a little mischievousness a little bit of tomfoolery. I do I do. I love it. I can't help it
Stronger your one k ramble ASMR is now my go-to for sleep. I'm glad you liked it
That's what happens if I don't give myself a script. It just turns into an absolute mess
Um, absolute mess. Um
I just like start rantin about anything that comes into my head
Fuck you
No, I love all the ASMR's all of them. Oh feels good man
Rip the video, but it was worth it. It was worth it. At least the audio's on patreon
Um
Uh, but yes, that is me
That's me take I'll at me means, but I do actually have some serious ASMR is coming out. Oh, I can't believe it
I actually need to record tapping ASMR. We'll still have my my nails. Can you? Oh, yes
Oh, that's right. Tingle for me. Tingle for me, baby. Yeah, you're tingling all over aren't you? Yes
Um
I actually need to record tingle ASMR tapping ASMR because I have my nails done which produces a really nice tapping sound
a live ASMR would be profit for clippers though
I
I went through my clips not many people are like clipping on youtube, which is perfect to find
Please don't actually feel like you have to do it. But if you ever like watch
Um by like a like if you're watching a vod and you've found a funny moment
Like clip it because I can see it and then send it on to an editor. Hi we fling something smells fishy. It's me. I'm sorry
Oh, is it fire we fling over there?
Sorry
Um, I literally cannot find the clip button. I do is it is it even on mobile phones?
On your wee iphone or your wee samsung or your wee
uh
I've forgotten the name of the chinese brand phone
Clipping is a hassle live. Is it?
There used to be a bunch of live ASMR videos and then youtube called them all. Yeah, I'm not surprised. I don't know what's
There's definitely a stealth thing like everyone's getting hit. I saw this other creator got hit with an ASMR thing recently as well
And I'm like bruv. Sorry, but this is just too obvious
There's definitely been a stealth update
um
And they're going buck wild for it because yeah
Who are you? I think yeah, that seems like a who are you?
It is the scissors above chat
Scissors above chat the clip button is available on the phone
But yeah, um
But don't be shy if you're ever watching a vod and you're like, oh that was mildly humorous and pro
It could possibly be turned into a clip. Thank you. Please. Uh, let me who where what I can't say who I
who I
No fun allowed on youtube once again. I'll be surprised legit
It used to be the wild west and as time progresses it just goes less
Also little annoying thing about the button if you join a stream
Where you were there since the waiting and you won't have a clip on because it's dumb so refresh
My only complaint. Sorry. My voice is starting to die. I think I need to get hydration shortly
Um, my only complaint with clips is that you can't share them anonymously your count is tight. Yes. I'm almost say that's also not
A fun element in before I'm going to start noticing that the people are clipping
You're just called straw knees clipper straw knees clipper clipper of straw knee because you guys are making like side accounts to clip
That would be cute
So about the tingles them are gonna fuse kinst ones. Oh, yeah, you're gonna keep I cannot believe I defeated the boss
in Legend of Zelda the first time
I thought we were in for a rage fest like I ate my burger. I stuffed it down my throat
I had my my cola on standby had some cheesy chips because I was like we're in for the long haul
I suck at this and oh my gosh like the patience the timing like everything couldn't have gone better
That was amazing. I was so happy with the results of that
A certified gamer moment. Vati isn't that hard? No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, you don't say that part out loud. Hold on a minute
Yeah, I I defeated the boss in one try. That's what you say. You don't say that the other part there
Refling, let me place my fingers on your lips. Refling. Don't ever say that again out loud with such confidence
Do I make myself clear the boss is hard? I defeated the boss in one. Okay
I
Watched the voice
You did so well. Thank you so much. I adore that game. I really do. I have absolutely no idea where the missing hearts are
Um, I I thought I could 100% it but now that the fail is like in the corrupted state of like everything is terrible
Ah, yes Skyrim on legendary
Look, I got a skyrim achievements to work. So I hope you're getting ready for some gamerscore collect in in july
Um, I have a bit of a bit of news. So as you know, my dad is coming home. Um
So I think my streams are gonna I can't believe I'm saying this
I'm going to be doing uh in quotation marks
regular stream of four hours
Daily
I probably can't go more than four hours without interrupting my dad. Um
So I know it's shocking. It's truly it's regular stream. I can't it's mortifying news and all honesty
Um, I'll see what my
The situation when my dad is because he's wanting to like take me
To like the shops and like go in like father daughter date type stuff because I've no seen him in a bit. Um
Um, I'm getting I'm gonna take me to a petting zoo. I think
Uh praying there's like actually animals there or it's just going to be like a goat in a field with like one of those like
Put 50 cents in here and turn the style and feed the animal
Can your stream addiction handle the it's going to be really weird
Because like in the most respectful way like I'm just so used to like talking all day long to you reeflings
So the thought of being like, oh no, I'm actually time gated
Like I I don't experience time gated like yesterday. I thought I was only going to stream for four hours
It turned out to be nine because yeah, like I'm not time gated. Um
Spend time with your dad. Thank you. Yes. Thank you for understanding. Um
I
It's gonna be weird
Like I need to pick out games that are short or games that can be done under eight hours because basically
I want like if we do like four hours for the first stream then the other four to complete the game in the next one
um
Like it's gonna be weird
You literally shoot him all the time. You think you're gonna accidentally talk to chat
What like when I'm talking to my dad? No, I'm gonna like show my dad everything. I'm going like these are the reeflings
These are all the like fan arts that have made of me. Maybe not the other stuff
Uh, this is like me and these are the girls and the girls will say hi and all that jazz
Let's call the jury campaigns. We're pretty short. Oh, maybe maybe
Make sure you pay a sheebie and a fondle in person for us
I didn't realize if someone gifts mercy member like if someone does membership gifts on mercy stream
The audio queue is me screaming fondle opism
I like mercy. Where did you even grab that from?
So, yeah, if you ever wanted to know what happens if you gift a membership on mercy stream
It's just me going fondle opism
Like
She yanked I had no idea she did that. I must have tickled her pink
I didn't it tickled everyone pink. I didn't think the name was that bad. I thought it was funny
Like oh, you're going to remember if a vtuber comes out and calls themselves fondle a bosom or you know, like
If I can only stream for four hours and who's going to yap to the reeflings for the other five
Literally, I'm like veal or girls girls besties. You're going to need to step up the reeflings are going to be uh needing
A yap off
Okay, you all start better start yapping about your special interests to put them asleep
They the reeflings cannot go to sleep unless they've heard of either one a capitalist rant
Two a rant about some random subject that
Reminded me of something because someone mentioned something really obtuse
Um or some sort of like video game relation thing. Okay, so girls get on it. Uh, I'm sure they'll do just fine
um
Yes, it's terrible, but it's absolutely hilarious. She's a memer too, you know
listen first is a
Family first, but you're my family reefling
It feels it feels horrible being pulled apart
like but
Still four hours. I think is more than adequate
Hopefully
Hopefully I don't have reefing I'm coping on now. There are times I will see what my dad's wanting to because there'll be days where
We don't go out and do anything. So I might be able to squeeze in a cheeky endurance here and there
um
But I'll probably have to
Go and like talk to him or like five minute intervals at like every hour or something
Just so he's just so I'm I'm still here dad. I'm still here. I'm just yapping away
uh
Him listening to the absolute ridiculous conversations we get up to he'll be like what's been sest
What is bindo about you don't want to know dad? You don't want to know
So
I say that as if my dad isn't uh doesn't know about internet culture to be honest. So it doesn't really matter
It doesn't matter in the end. Um
We need every five minutes of your dad because we need to thank him. Oh, no
He's like insert legal name here and legal address kind of uh parent
So yeah, no not happening. Um, he might knock on door. He told me I was um
What's that talking to him a wee bit ago?
Um, and he was like I might bang on the door just so you know, I'm awake and I'm like great
So I get to have a heart attack and freak out. Sure. Give him a patreon subs
Meet that refund right there meet that refund right there. No
um
No, he didn't he doesn't he doesn't know those kind of no, then he knows that um, you know a voice slag
Um and all that but no, uh, he no no, you know, you know, no none of that none of that
Uh, no, not that kind of path. No, he's not a step dad. Um, put it that way. He's not step dad. He's he's mad at
mad at
Um, but yes, I need to think of like shorter games. I think stray is probably going to be on the roster
Um
You're wrong for that one chief. Yeah. Yeah, I'm gonna be I'm gonna I'm gonna you're you kind of wrong for that one
Um, like actual dad, but not a dad. I like I see
Hope we get are you winning strongy? Oh, do you want him to do voice lines just for the hell of it?
I was gonna see if I can do that halo playthrough with them, but I don't know if it's possible because
Um
It's take it. I don't know if I could set them up on it or not
I might just do like the classic interview
Thing like if you guys have any questions for my dad because I'm sure when I was going to be like
What was it like that your daughter's a slag and then he goes well the house is paid off and I get to retire next year
So feels pretty good. And then it's like, oh, everyone gets rolled in smoke that has ever said anything nasty
Um make it a video. Yes. I thought about doing like an interview video where it's like because vtubers make it such a big deal
My parents know I'm a vtuber
Like
Would they not know that you work at Tescos as well? Am I missing some key elemental factor?
Do your parents like not just you know
Do your parents not root for you and everything you do like are they not in your corner being like? Yeah, that's amazing. Go strongy go
No
Well, that's what I have anyway, so it's not it's never been like a
Oh my god, my parents don't know what I'm doing. Please don't tell it. Well, of course my parents know what I'm doing
I'm having a fucking carry on
Do you think if you think I can't stop yam to you guys I'd be telling everything
My parents know every little detail
Well, I tell you a secret
A strongy mama strongy like she be
I
Mama strongy is a harem
and
She really likes her voice and she finds her voice quite soothing
And she's like oh, she has a really good voice really good voice. Yeah
um
She got on at me about emi's chest, so I don't talk to emi about I don't talk about emi to her
Because she was like a strongy. I'm no sure about that and I'm like look mom
Mom you have to understand
Peytan is in Peytan stonks are in
What does dad think about she be?
I don't think dad really has much of an opinion. He doesn't really say much
He like knows everyone's designs. I tell you what I'll get him to record his reaction to the designs
I could probably do that in the interview type thing with him
And be like because I've told them countless times. I'm called strongy
He knows I'm called strongy
And I know for a fact if I sit him down and record and be like name this feature bar he'll go
um
Oh
And he can't come out of them
strongy's mum's a hates flies. No, she doesn't hate that she's flat
She dislikes the
Young girl appearance
Um of emi and she thought it was a bit messed up and I'm like like I can see it
But I've been staring at icing emi for over a year now. It's just thing. I like it doesn't mean anything
Like I tried to be like well, it's just the opposite of a cleavage really
It's just a concave chest because she's got nothing there and mum was named
She was kind of seeing it and she was kind of no seeing it and she was like right as long as yous are all safe and happy
That's all she's as long as yous are all safe and happy. That's my mum
The fact that it's a lollipop I
aim my mum's
Experience with like japanese and anime and that I forced her to watch kill the kill with me
Which has a lot of fan service and she was like strongy. What is this fish and I'm like honestly
It is actually quite embarrassing watching anime in front of your parents. So don't recommend that
Oh
Lollipop love everyone involved is an adult the end end of story. Yes, everyone is safe. Everyone is happy everyone
Ah, yes, yeah kill kill son. I love kill kill
There's a very good video game and kill kill
I uh a fan game
A fan game of kill kill
And it is it is insane quality
It's not a fighting game. No, um, we're a bit tied up in the game
Is it by zone it might be because the quality was off the charts of the game
Like honestly like something the development team for the anime made themselves. I was like good. Oh, I know that one
I used to go absolutely nuts for that. I cannot have countless times. I have spilled my ink to it
It is a fantastic game
Um, it's outrageous. I know but I don't care
Fun fact, bible black was my introduction. Have I seen that? I don't think I have
My dad likes to watch anime with me sometimes the one he likes the most
Was his high school at the dead. I wonder why oh, no, is it bad?
Gaming bless your heart. I'm trying. I'm trying
Oh, I know you mean gaming isn't it?
Do you see yourself playing on elsewhere? Yeah. Um, there's this orc game that I'm absolutely tantalized by that
I've never played it. I absolutely want to do like a
Type of like live like we play it and do stuff together live type of stream
um
Uh, my only issue
I wanted it to be free
But someone raised the issue
That having it accessible like that negates the audios and I'm like, oh, well I kind of agree
Which is a bit shitty. I don't know what the solution is to that situation is
I don't have a solution yet. I still have time july is kind of when it you know things start to break
What do you mean by that? Um, so patreon's appeal is because you get very unique audios of scenarios
um
But I really don't want another subscription
I
Um, I don't want to charge anymore
Because the fucking membership was one dollar more than I wanted it to be so I'm already raging at that
And I don't have a solution yet. I don't have a
How does it negate it?
Because it's like here's free access
to this content
That arguably could be a lot better
Um, because some people aren't into the audios for like the rp aspect
And it's like well, you can
you know
It's uh, it's a bit tricky to navigate at this stage. I don't have a solution
I don't have a
finality either
I
Cheap vods via subscription
Now vauding I might agree to a very small even if it's like a dollar
I kid you not a dollar for vods. I think is agreeable
For the actual live stream. I think all you would have to do is follow
And that's it. I'm quite happy with that solution. That might be the solution
A dollar for vod access
I think is fair
And then free access to the actual live if you can get it in time
If it's all strong even that punishes people that have worked that punishes people in this time
Rob
Look at any other agency and be like, are you getting value for money compared to us? Yes or no
Please I am trying. I'm trying to make everyone happy. It is not possible. Please work with me
Work with me. These girls need to move out. These girls need to eat these girls need to find success these girls
You know
Fucking give them your money
Be nice to the girls. They're trying to achieve stuff. Okay. I've already got everything I need with my wiflings. Okay
You'll be to watch small fee votes is a pretty common setup. Okay
There's no perfect solution, but that is one. Yes, there is no perfect solution
In the wise words of captain
I cannot remember his name of the star chick enterprise
Captain Picard you can do everything right and still it goes wrong or something like that. I can't remember
I don't see if it will affect patreon stuff. Okay. Well, hopefully it doesn't if it does then
I
Because um patron if you didn't know uh if you ever feel but oh, it's only five dollars
And patreon statistically and very shortly should and will be the girl's biggest income source
Um very quickly. So don't be afraid to support mom patreon
Uh undercut in the market undercut the market five dollars for four audios undercut in the market as well as access and archive to anything
They produce on youtube. Yeah
Okay
Undercut the market. Um, yes, it should actually be their biggest income source. Um, that's the plan anyway
It looks like it's actually happening. You know that
and
I can only speak for myself at this point
But
Yeah, my harry on
Are you kidding me right now hit by the pope. I wanted to stay up for your stream since it starts at 2 a.m
Here, but I ended up heaping out of comfort of your voice. Thank you for rambling. Thank you flaws for the super chat
Are you got floppy as your profile picture? That's floppy, isn't it? It is. Um
Thank you for the super chat and uh, please rest well unless you're up already
You tried to stay up for the stream but passed out
Oh
We've got a thousand wines bomb
Flop a little big flop like who's gonna go. Hmm. Now that this free. I don't want to sell up on patreon hard
You'd be surprised. Um
Some of the patreon feedback is like that shit insane
I could probably talk about it a bit more as time develops. I might even make a short out of it, honestly
um, you would be surprised how
People's like exit survey you can leave it if you leave someone's patreon. You can leave a message and it's like an exit survey
You would be surprised on the reasons
Why someone is like i'm no longer supporting you type thing
My biggest problem is if I want to watch all the girls
I don't have time to have to make sacrifices that I don't yet know if I am ready to make
Oh, thank you our own reaper
for the five and um
Yeah the
Yeah, it's kind of hard to keep up with all the girls at once. Uh, definitely not that easy. Um
But what was I saying? I've completely forgotten. No
My brain's too small to do multiple things at once. Can I give an example an example of what i'm so sorry
I've completely forgotten what I was talking about
um
I
Hearing the girls are really happy about how they are doing. Hopefully they can all make their situation better. Yeah, like I think
Emmy's want to move out. Aces want to move out. Azura's want to move out. Shuby's want to move out. Everyone's want to move out
Uh mercy wants to move out because
Her parents make it a nightmare to record
I'm not even I'm not even gonna pretend
It should be like oh my parents are up. Sorry
No, that's fine. That's fine. Just leave it. Leave it last minute. It's fine. It doesn't make a difference
Oh crazy
Patreon feedback. Uh, yeah stuff like uh no longer want to support because
um
You made this one audio that I don't enjoy and it's like
Now don't get me wrong
Please don't ever feel forced to like throw your money at
Creators if you genuinely don't enjoy what they put out
But some of the stuff is like you made one audio. I do not like out of so many audios that you have made
I am gone and it was like, okay
Why would you even leave that in the feedback like don't be realistic? I don't know if it like you need to be told to your face
There's no way in heck one creator can make something that you enjoy a hundred percent of the time
Like as soon as I come out saying that I didn't mind sounding. Oh, oh, strongy bad. Oh, right. That's it. Get it out right now
I've got straw. Um
I'm teasing I'm teasing
Uh five minutes and 56 seconds into the audio you made a mouth sound. I did not like honestly it can be like that
Um, I'll definitely show some examples strongy's a bad girl
Who made you listen to that audio like come on. Yes, it definitely feels a bit like
I
Don't know if people feel forced to put something
I don't know how it looks when you like disengage from someone's patreon subscription
But I don't know if people feel forced to put an answer down
You do not have to put an answer down and insult the creator on the way out just uh, just a quick tip for you
You know, you don't have to insult the creator on the way out
Even though like you literally put your money where your mouth was and supported the creator like is
I will definitely make a short about it and show some examples because it's uh rather humorous
It can be rather humorous
Or when they make an assumption about everything you'll make in the future off of two posts
Bruh, I felt so bad for she be
I felt so bad for she be she was getting a bit of flak because the first audio just happened to be an s scenario
And she made three
d scenarios and one s and it was voted on the one s
And she got so much flak and I'm like do I have to like come out and explain like how this works?
like
I am I am happy to say we do have a schedule that will be posted next month
Where you can see what's coming up ahead
So um, if you are on a monthly
basis like you
You sign up and then sign off again. You'll be able to see what's coming up
I will try my best to put the tags, but I'm absolutely rubbish at making tags. I'm not used to it
So it's hard to get used to it because I'm struggling me. I'm struggling. I'm not smart enough for this
Okay, when this pops we're going to make a cup of tea and get some food in our belly because I'm getting a bit hungry
Yeah, I think that would have changed the results. There is going to be that first plot d
scenario
I
I just I didn't write it at the time because I at the point I had actually wrote 3d for her
And then I was like, okay
She needs one s at least and somehow you guys miraculously voted on the one s. I was literally the odds were what one in four
But anyway, I thought it was really funny her first audio was sd
I mean you do have to remember
Am I allowed to say that?
No, maybe no
Maybe another time. Have you thought about posting demos? Um
No, um, I actually no, I don't mean this in a bad way. Please do not think I'm
That's fantastic
Um, please do not think I am honing in on your comment. Um, even though I am responding to your question though
I do not believe
In the need this sounds terrible and I hope it doesn't come across as bad as it sounds
I don't think a preview is needed for such a low
Undercut of the market as well as you can try it for for you can trial it for five dollars
You can trial it. You don't have to keep it on afterwards
um
I do under like and the girls already post stuff for free on the alt twitter like I feel like you get enough of a
Situation of is this going to be worth it or not? And if it's not worth it
Hopefully that fight, you know, you're not going to spend five dollars that you actually need like so
It's kind of like
It's not even a lose
There's like no loss as well because you've actually directly supported the girl like that you've helped them like
Move out. You've helped them maybe upgrade their equipment that um, they didn't want to ask management for
isura
Per isura. She was too shy to ask for a new iphone. So I had to buy her one like right before debut
um
But she got it so our iphone's all juicy as far as i'm aware
Is there a no yeah, it just seemed like there's a lot of extremes for the first people
and
I
Actually can't make a comment
I mean the first the first month is always chaos. Um
People getting used to folk folk filtering themselves folk getting filtered like it's just the way it is
Um, but like once things settle down, I mean
I mean she I think I was in the the reef lines are all settled down
Are we not like we're already jumping straight into endurance stream. We've got elden ring next week. Hello. No
We've got elden ring in a couple of days like hello
Um, I'm ordering take away on elden ring day. Yeah, you don't have to tell me twice. I assure you
um
I will absolutely like I feel like we're we're settled and you guys already know where the start score is with me
Um, you know, you have to let the girls cook a little bit, you know, let them get comfy and all that jazz
You're gonna catch she be stream. Oh she'd be live anything for any harem members. Sheepster's live mercy collab
Uh, see you in the mercy collab. Yes, I will see you in the mercy club. Thank you for the tip. Bye
Um, please do watch emmy is collabing with uh a person's name that I forget right now
Unfortunately, and she be is live with inscription if you enjoy inscription. Yes, the elden ring dlc is coming out. Um
I bloody hope I've done it on the right day
I will download the dlc. We are starting a fresh save. Um, I don't know if it's one of those things where you can
Just run to the dlc area. I mean, maybe if it's appropriate or unless it's like harder than kaolin type thing
Can't wait to play elden ring. It's out today
That I purposely push it a day back is elden ring tomorrow
Eaps
Oh, no, I don't want ashes
Elden ring today
Show me my youtube channel so I can look at my own
Um
So I can look at my own
Schedule all children. Yeah, elden rings tomorrow. I'm heart rate monitor and all that. Yeah
Elden ring dlc unlocks in like two hours. Yes, make sure you
purchase
Um, yeah, don't be surprised
Um, when you see a ton of vtuber's playing elden ring, I think all of us are about to go fucking mental for it
Man, it breaks my heart. Strone's providing so much literally and figure out the quality and quantity why sometimes even for free
And some people are still asking for more
Uh, it's human nature to want more. It's fine. I understand how it works. Like there's no point in being like, you know mad
um
Like you can only do so much and um, you know, you know, you're in yourself your limitations
Like I wouldn't push myself to like have a silly goal of like one asmr video pair
A 1000 subs type thing is the most dangerous of all the girls
She sounds so sweet and innocent and then you look at her patreon
And I feel like I should report myself to the police. What steady on I wrote her plots
Uh, I will say they're they're my plots. I've been written for roughly two to three months
Some of them are actually only two months
Uh, and then the scriptmaster comes in and I think the scriptmaster will just work as far better than mine
Um, so I think you'll like them a heck of a lot more
Which reminds me I actually need to send off an editing batch away because me completed her july audio space
Shawnee you're maoshi, but I do love all the girls and care about them
I want all of yours to be happy. Yes. I want them to be happy too. It's um, it's very interesting some some um
I you know
I thought it was a pretty
Honestly, it just feels like I've spawned in another five strongies and you know reeflings
If that makes sense like, you know
Mercy snippets
Strongly reeflings like it feels like I've just spawned in another five that just do their own thing and have a good time
And I mean that's what it's all about at the end of the day
I don't think it's you know
Fucking chasing numbers and oh my god
Must must must have this must do this must do that and it's like no, I really have fun
Like I get to reach out to other vtubers and be like hey, I'd love to do ASMR with you
I'll write the script. It's like a fun little small goofy thing. You know no stress no fuss like it lets me
You know interact with people in the vtuber community like it's it's like such a little blessing. Um
I mean like our
Holy shit. I get to claim that this is work. I get to claim that sitting in edgeville on world three eight right now
uh doing wine
Uh talking to reeflings is work in quotation marks like nah nah the same work
Less like a corporal more of a guild of indies honestly, it's probably a more accurate thingy. Um
Just that there was a lot of massive money back in to be honest. Um
Yes, I'm going to try and get the girls at least 5k subscribers this
Month, so I'm going to send Icy and Azura an ASMR. I'm going to get Azura to do heartbeat ASMR
and kissing
Maybe not kissing because I actually saw an ASMRist got their video removed for kissing
I think Azura sleep aids heartbeat cuddle sound soft breathing would go very well
She be actually has a sleep aid audio coming out. I ordered the artwork
Um, and it's already here and I need to edit and get it ready to click send
What do you mean? I'm doing far too much
Work all at once. What are you talking about? No, not the kissing. Yeah, I don't know
No, so you can do like soft breathing, but for some reason if you've got a 3d or you can't go up in the ear
Make it make sense. Like I I've no got clue. Make it make sense. Thank you again iron reaper for the tip
I'm pretty sure I didn't read your name out because we were all thinking about how evil emmy is
But emmy's a good kind of evil
Um, oh my tummy is rumbling
I can't believe it. I may actually my human body needs to eat and hydrate
Um, do you have a sleep aid audio coming out? Yes, I
Haven't made it. I haven't written it
But if there's anything you want in a sleep aid audio, let me know
Um, I was probably just going to do the old classic route. Is there a cat in this room?
Vigo
I'm losing it
I'm so dehydrated. I'm losing it and I think Vigo's in the room right now
Uh, I might have to start making a lot of the sus ASMR member only
Hmm
I don't want to overwhelm the girls. Um with work requirements
Um, like for me, you know streaming doing three member streaming weekend streaming every day is not problem
But I am aware that people have limitations
that I don't
um
And they experience things that I don't
So it makes it kind of like not a dangerous playing field
But like I try to make things as super easy and simple like that ASMR. I got she be to talk to make sorry
um
I think it was like less than five minutes of dialogue and I know people might be like, oh my god
Why aren't you giving us a massive amount of dialogue?
And it was like I need to manage the girl's stress levels like needy streamer overload
I cannot overload them with work whilst they're trying to stream
I'm trying to entertain because they might struggle with things that I don't experience because I don't feel uncomfortable
Or like I just feel literally right at home. Um
But humble brag. No, I'm not even like in a mean way. I just like I need to be so careful and so cautious
And like it's scary because like
It's not like the girls have a hp bar and a stress bar that I can look at
And be like, are you telling me the truth? Like I was checked in on emmy and emmy's like, I'm fine
I'm cloud nine. I was like pinky promise me right now because I I don't know
I actually don't know if you're good, but I think emmy is good and she was good and all that, you know
Like if the girls had freaking hp bars and stress bars
I would be a lot easier to navigate what I want them to do
But like at the moment I'm having to be like patient and let them settle and like they've taken break days
And maybe on break days they'll record the youtube ASMR's for me like
It's um
And who's thinking about you the reeflings are thinking about me silly
The reeflings give me energy the reeflings give me life
Hmm
Literally I rolled out of bed 10 minutes before stream. I was moody. I made a cup of tea
Um, I got set up the moment I come on live. I go in a massive round in rave. You guys fill me with with energy
With determination. I've been filled with your determination
Um
Like yeah, you don't you don't you don't all worry about me. I get life like when you guys comment
Oh, your ASMR was so cute. All the stream was so cute. I'm a vod watcher. Here's a clip like
Uh fun facts Johnny. We love you. Love you to replay
If they had hp bars emmy's would enjoy if hers was low munkos
Uh, I would actually mess around with the idea of a feature management game
I think that's very on topic, but uh, I don't have the development team
I don't have a development team at all for video games, but I do have the funds
But I would have to write out the game and I don't have time to write out the game right now
I wrote out the bare bones of my cookie clicker game
um
Totally not inspired by legend of zelda by the way, uh
Yeah, I do not have time to write video games
Which is annoying because it's one of the projects I'm gonna do as that what the call the kids call it now
She steals our energy. He's like, he's real emmy's hp bar has an inverse relationship. We're a happy bar
Gen two game just saying oh, I already know what the gen two game is and the gen three game is I've already picked it out
Um, I realized very quickly whilst I was commissioning the gen one game
Oh wait games actually take a lot of money and time to produce. Um, so I already know what the
The gen two is uh free to play video game of an alternative nature is um
I'd be very surprised if anyone would guess it's because
It's based on pre-established games, but we've
We've borneified it and you basically can
Swing with the girls in the generation in that game
I
Will go like
She's 10 steps ahead of us when I say it took a year for the girls to pop up
I wasn't kidding like you have to think ahead like you have to think of events
You have to think of their birthdays. You have to think of their doughnut thongs. You have to think of alternative outfits
You have to think
Right, uh, we've made the offer if they sign on another year. They can get another alternative outfit
All right, the girl's gonna want a group alternative outfit of a certain theme like
There's like a possibility of a timeline that next year in june
If we're all standing we might all have like goth variations of our designs something like that. Um
Like there's a lot. Please not candy crush. No, it's not candy crush
You're welcome
Read and list bonus months. Yes, like we so the split is 80 20 and if they sign on another year that increases to
um
85 15
And they also get an alternative costume
on the house by
Like the development team
But they can like dictate what all outfit they want. That's perfectly fine. We don't have an issue with that
But we pay for it as I like thanks for signing on for another year. Yippee
Will it be a card game? No, there's not a card game
I actually can only remember the first two
um
The first two generations game
type
Based well, it'd be a mobile. No, it's a mobile. Are you joking me?
Hi, I just got home from working realize I missed sharing a smart any chance
It's currently on patreon at this moment in time. Um, I'm going to upload it to twitter
I need to buy twitter
Oh, we popped. Yay
What are we?
We're 83. Wait, we may actually make 85. My prediction is true. I can't believe that
Wow, what's that? Yeah
Cuttles turns into a sea jargon just like pokemon evolution cleolix and animal. Yeah. Yeah. That's a really good split. Yes, um
because of the freedoms and how low is the
As I've said this before the actual upkeep the up. Yeah. Yeah, the upkeep the upkeep really ain't that much
Ain't that much at all? I don't know what to tell you. It does not cost that much. Um
Probably the biggest cost right now is clippers unironically sending away these clip edits to be made
um
I have three clippers for the girls and they all unanimously
Unanimously needed a break all roughly at the same time
Um, which has led me to seek out a clipper for my own strongy stuff at the moment
Uh, because I've completely abandoned like my youtube shorts
Um in favor of the girls at the moment. Um, shebe's shorts are currently all getting limited
So I can't promote her shorts. I can't put advertisement money into her shorts
Um her praise short was supposed I was going to put money into for advertisement. I can't because she's got too much
About 1.8k wines. Oh god. I don't know if I'm gonna make it in this room. Um
But yeah, we we struggle
Remember to rest by the way you have a collab too. Yes. No, I am I am I'm going offline when
Uh, Azura comes on which gives me two hours rest, which is more than adequate. Um, I'm talking to mercy one hour before
the stream starts
um, and
I just wanted to get some cheeky runescaping in because there's a few levels. We uh, definitely need to get up
How do you work on their videos or what? Um, maybe like an edit and thumbnail
um, so I basically
um
Go through their clips and if I find something clippable
I will send it to an editor, but I've actually asked them to do that because I can't scour all their clips at once
It's not possible. Um
But I have pre-made shorts I make of them that's like insider knowledge about the vtuber agency or insider vtuber stuff
Like mercy's shorts. Oh my god. I'm so sorry to expose mercy like this
Mercy never wrote any of her shorts. That's all me
The short about like senpai am I blonde did you look should I been blonde or like this is what goes wrong as a v
These are that's me. I'm sorry. It's all me
I'm telling her what to say
Exposed called it. Yes. Um, but it's me. That's pulling the strings. It's me. That's wrote these scripts and
It's me piloting her mecca and sending it off to the editor because I don't want to stress the talents out
With like having to do all these bits and bobs in between streaming. It's not good for it to reduce their stress as much as possible
I'm like
Putting it on me because I can handle these stress levels. Like I don't even feel stress
You know what I feel frustrated that I've let the girls down with a short scenario, but it's slowly evening out like what we're
I think I'm probably gonna try and see if I can find another editor to have on standby
because
We've got someone that skill isn't quite there yet and I'm like
I've need to pay the big bucks to get the edits. I want a new pair. You're such a hard-working beast
Stroney is actually all a veeler
Yeah, I wasn't kidding when I said I was icy snow paws
Fuck I can't do our accent right now because I'm smiling
I'm doing the most stereotypical accent
Dada, do you like my photos on twitter at twitter.com slash
ic snow
Do you like my tummy data?
I can't do it. I can't do it. It's terrible. If we ever do
Like april fools. I have to go on ic because I can't do anyone else's voice
Okay, real Michael. Hi
Wow, yeah, like I can't do mersey's voice. I can't do emmy
I can't do she be our reserves for that, but I'm gonna sneeze in a second
Okay, sorry
I sneezed and I hiccuped
Um
Oh, I can feel another sneeze
Bless you. Thank you
A little cheeky hiccup after sneeze anyone gauge on hate. Salut. Bonjour
Bonjour a va
Oh, oui, bien bien. Merci  toi. Oh, oui. Je jouais
Euh, lundskip
Uh, yeah, sorry, that's me just absolutely losing it. I think I am gonna actually have to get some food and hydration
Because I am starting to get a wee bit delirious
We've got a tunnel vision is occurring my outside viewing point. Definitely not as good
Uh, qu'on a mschit qu'on a mschit messes. Um
Um
You just got some snacks you really can't wait anymore like god damn it streamer get off
Yes for any harem members that are lurking in the shadows, please be advised that none other than she be cotton boom is live right now
Now you get yourself water and food correction. Yeah
I'm so focused on the wines though. You'll make it. It's less than an hour if you lock in. Okay
Right, we'll have a very quick break. I'm gonna make honey tea
Um reefling if you could just uh start preparing for the ink for the tea. That'd be great. Um
Yeah, ready? Okay
Such an ASMR announcement
Hmm reefling sometimes you have to force this woman to take care of herself. Remember that. Thank you for the great yap fest
Gonna give she be some love. Yes, please do not be afraid to show any of my gen mates love. I have absolutely no
Whatever the word is is a jealousy
What is it? You know what we should actually create a name for the vtuber jealousy phenomenon
I'm here for it. We should create a new term right now in the english language
for when a vtuber is like
Don't watch other vtuber's but like not because they're like yandere and like mercy doesn't count because she's yandere, you know what i'm saying
But like we should actually call it and it's like it's the female vtuber phenomenon
Where they get jealous envy tuba. Maybe envy. Mmm
Envy cute possessive girlfriend
Extranged tuba possessive. It's literally called a vendetta. Wait
What's the definition of it?
Vendetta
The effort initiative all done. Let's pull up google for this one lads because I actually don't know it off the top of my head
What a vendetta is
Let me just brew some wine then you make me vendetta a blood feud in which the family of the murdered person seeks vengeance
Or a prolonged bitter quarrel with with or campaign against someone. Okay. That one seems more like it
A bit of a a bit of a bitterness. How about that a bit of bitterness?
Yeah, it's probably a bit more
Don't be self-centered
Wrong definition. Isn't that called parasocial? I don't
No, isn't parasocial when someone wants to show up to your house?
I thought that's what parasocial the definition of parasocial is
When someone genuinely wants to show up to your house. It's like
Serion mate. Serion
The convention sure show up to the convention my house. No, sorry. Uh, gimme. He's gonna start freaking out. No, that's the stalker
Okay, no, that's talk. Wait, so then what's parasocial parasocial is getting attached online
There's levels, but yeah, that would be better
Yeah, I used to have people that said they were going to show up to my house. Uh, maybe don't do that
Maybe don't do that
Parasocial is projected one-sided friendship. Parasocial would be me saying strone's my best though when she doesn't even know my name
And yet I can read your name in chat right now shopping behavior
Is it is it like warped perception of reality?
One-sided relationship with someone you've never met so you actually see yourself as someone's significant other. Ah, okay. Okay
So
It would be reality is not in check. I remember sweet Anita talking about her stalker situation
I don't know Benny you guys heard about it
It was like the guy literally bought a house across the road from her and would sleep in her garden in that and like peep through
her litter box
And like wake her up during the night and all that and she's just the police refuse to do anything and she's just like
Oh wait, I don't know if there is an update. Maybe I'm making that up
But she basically has accepted that the only way the guy's ever gonna be dealt with via the law
Is she'll be murdered, which is actually quite a common case
For stalking situations, I wouldn't be surprised if there might be new stalking laws coming out in the next few years because
uh, yeah
The parasocial knife cuts both ways because just just as we get attached to vtuber vtuber get attached to us
Yes, I agree with that sentiment
And like we said strong, he's my wife and I wasn't joking
Ah, right
But you know my husband
Husband riefling husband riefling has
husband
sling
Reef bend reef bend
Don't be co-dependent to the corporal. Oh, no. Oh, if I guess it's out of the peeler allegations. I might allow it
I just make the honey tea around here
That's curious, it's curious
It's like one of those forbidden topics you're not supposed to talk about but when you open when you openly talk about it
It's like, okay. Okay. We're just getting perspectives in everyone's thought process. Well, it's almost like when you openly discuss things and
Instead of just assume things behind closers
like wild wild
Husbandling husband, that's kind of cute
And we're played runescape. So I have no idea what's going on. It seems like a just-chan. It is absolutely a just-chan
We are basically doing the crazy crazy task
of
reducing
Oh, it popped
Let's go. Okay. Maybe I should go for food now like actually go for food this time
Um, yes. No runescape is just an opportunity for me to yap your ear off for hours on end
I'm so sorry. You have fallen for my pranks yet again. You have fallen for my ruse. Um, I have misled you astray
And to think that this is just a regular game. It's not. It's just another excuse for me to tell you about the capitalist
I keep thinking that level sound is actually a jumpstart. Oh, I'm so sorry. How loud do you listen?
Do you not listen on a low volume? Please make sure you're not listening too loud
Um, because I will break your eardrums. Uh, when I get too excited. Do I make myself clear that husband briefly?
Aw
Thank you for the tip Zarian that husband literally me. Have I seen any that come literally me?
No, I think our new version is that baby is literally me and I'm the father. I like that
I'm enjoying that quite a lot right now. Um
The husband and the baby is me. I like that hydration check right. Okay fine fine. I'm freaking I'll go get food
I can't believe it. I can't believe my bodily functions need to take priority
Man, why can't I just stream for hours on end? Like honestly, don't be so rude
But your voice even if excited is fine at high volume the level up is not
Okay, even great football you happen. If I had a headless headset
I would like take you to the kitchen with me and I'll be like, hi Gimli
I bet you Gimli's gonna come flying around the corner the moment I leave this room
Thank you for tip, right? I'll be give me four minutes
It takes like four minutes for the kettle to boil and I'll see if there's anything I can microwave if not
I might be ordering a cheeky takeaway after um, I'll host a I'll be direct into Azura Azura is playing
That one game I've already forgotten
What's the name of the game Azura is playing?
A whole four minutes. I have you on 5.1 surround system. Please bless me. That's Scottish boys. No
Yeah, yes Azura is playing Little Nightmares, which is a fantastic 10 out of 10 game
Um, I'm very excited to see her playthrough of that and I will be
Hopefully if it's a good stream, I might be able to get highlight reel made of that stream
I'm gonna see if I can get a buckshot roulette highlight reel made of my stream possibly
I think you deserve more takeaway. That's just because
Mm-hmm. Mm-hmm. That's mm-hmm. Yeah
Okay, I will actually go get food and get a drink. Oh, I'm lightheaded because of dehydration
I just shook my head up and down there. Okay. I will actually go that was scary. I will be back in four minutes
So
Are you squiddling me right now?
You
Oh
Yeah, I kind of scared myself
With a lightheaded moment. I have so much food with me right now. It's like funny. I think so before though
This is Gimli and Bebo are
Waiting to launch themselves in the down room
Okay
So if you hear some my awing it's very possible. I can still hear him
I ain't going to do it. We need to be sure she takes care of herself
Yeah, I'm good to go. Okay. Oh
Hold on ain't it bro
Okay, I have uh leftover yippies
There's five had enough to actually cook them away
I've got tea
I want a Nutella bar. I've got a bowl of leftover cheesy chips. I've got my
Chocolate covered raisins, which I've yet to successfully eat. I've taken them out twice now
The novel I've got wee blueberry muffin. I don't know if you can hear me spank it a little bit and then
The piece de resistance. I have a um fruit juice and a glass because you know
Um
It's good for you and it's got like seven different types of fruit and it's the only thing that's
Probably keeping me alive right now. Um successfully
and
Yeah, I'm about to stuff my face and drink and get a ton of sugar in my body because that's scary
I feel this one's a good girl damn straight good girl
I'm inhaling these chips, please you're welcome to eat with me if you so desire, itadakimasu
It's like actual fruit. This has apple coconut water
and mango passion fruit dragon fruit
and
It's like really healthy
Uh try and eat one
Eat one I try and drink one at least every week because I don't eat a lot of fruit
But I eat tons of vegetables. She says that she eats cheesy chips that doesn't count. Um
But I'll try and have one every week because I think it's keeping the scurvy away
Um
I just never seem to buy fruit like I feel like it always goes off where it's always like
Not like a way too late to eat it and I don't want to be wasteful, you know
What percent is juice? What does that mean?
A hundred percent no concentrate zero added sugar zero artificial
Um it says on the the patent game
So it's supposed to be super good for me. Hopefully if not, I've been lied to how dare you how dare I be lied to
Mm-hmm
Yeah, you have to eat on the day you get it literally like sauce but
I've been so disappointed with supermarkets lately that I've been using like
independent stores and the quality of the and it's so cheaper and so different quality as well
Like these super fucking mental national chains is just like nothing
My god
You forget how good food tastes until you eat it. Oh, yeah, this should this should bang him
Let me shake up my fruit juice so I can uh confirm that I've had my five a day for today
Mm
They say the Mediterranean diet is the best one you can do because they have like so much fruit and veg in it
And fish as well
Fish is good for you, but the only fish I can eat the sun's terrible. I'm just so pretty. Oh, I just spilled my juice
I spilled a little bit on my mouse mat. So now it gets to be on me and yeah, oh have a napkin. Thank god. I have a napkin
Okay bottoms up I uh, we support local businesses
Mm-hmm
Oh this shit busting for real. I love mango mangoes delicious fruit
Yeah, like cod fish and chips haddock is the only fish I can eat because it's fucking battered and fried and I'm like, bro
How how how more British can I get? I tried to eat salmon couldn't have it. I don't mind shrimp
um
Shrimp isn't that bad, but there's not really many things. I have it with a baked potato, but I don't have it with any else
Maybe I should try and make a shrimp salad to get more fish in me because fish is like really good for you
When it's not full of mercury thanks to humans and dumping things in the water where it doesn't belong
Oh good
Oh fucking good
Almost finished it
And then we'll move on to the next items
who will
So who will be the refund to clean the mouse pad? No, not you
Lost genuinely thank you for being a caring person strongy
Be sure to get enough rest for yourself. We love you underscore love
Oh, thank you little reflin
And thank you Brian for announcing little refling's words. Thank you for so it's very kind of you not you don't need to worry about me
Okay, you don't need to worry about me
I
Have the tism and it enables me to do things and that's why I can do all this stuff
So don't worry about me. Okay
If you mean forgetting to eat and drink that's literally because I'm having such a good time
Like streaming and I don't really want to like interrupt that moment for a few moments, you know
What a strange pee is it polska? I don't know what it is. I actually don't know what currency that is
I'm so sorry. Please forgive me. Is it peso weaponized?
I know that feeling yes
Like I'm just getting something like I'm sure you guys have been lost in the sauce
Like if you've ever played a video game and then like you kind of wake out wake up from your trance on the other side
You're like, oh my god, I haven't eaten or drank and like a couple of hours type thing
Like it's kind of like that with streaming like I just cannot shut up
Uh, I love it. I'll have an amazing time with the reflins. Hopefully the content is good
I know some people runescape residents sleeper. But look, it's one of my goals. Okay. Once it's once it's done
We don't have to come back. Okay. Once it's done
And we're doing a watch along and the next one. So we have like a topic of conversation
So don't worry about having to like talk and we are going to do the
Is it john wick is john wick. We're going to do the john wick series
Whilst I do wines in the background and we might do it like that until we get very close to the end
And I'll just do one big massive. Yeah, because I kind of saw myself six there. Thank you for coming and remember
I appreciate it. I'll try the member ASMR in two days time. Wink wink
I'm here for shawty not for the game. What do you mean? You're not here to watch me put wine and water to get
Sorry grapes and water together
Don't be silly
Don't be silly. This is the elusive gameplay that you have always craved your entire life. No vtuber has done it before
Yes, a vtuber most likely has done it. Apparently john wick five is in production. That better be a joke
I wanted to watch a series that had a finished end
Uh, should we watch a different type of series then? What could we watch?
What is something that has free free films? That's good
Does transformers was there like five transformers or am I making that up?
No john wick isn't finished. Oh come on, right
Maybe we'll pick something else then
I want a start of a story and I want an end of a story. Is that too much to ask for?
Because it clearly is
Just a a cheeky series spider-man
No, I don't think spider-man would do honestly watching story play runescape makes me question getting back into that
I'm only concerned with that keeper runescapes that you can pick it up and drop it at any time
And like get a feel for like doing the free stuff
Like I don't think you need membership to buy wine
So if you wanted night night cooking like you can do it whilst like getting items and all that
Um kung fu panda if you ignore the force. I've actually not seen the other kung fu pandas. I only saw the first one
Maybe we should watch kung fu panda and we just pretend the force doesn't we do not see the four
I'm
Before we end up nerding out on star wars, but that's about nine installments technically
The godfather I've never seen the godfather before it's like a three installments
Wow
Okay, fruit juice is finished. I am now being nutritionalized in fruit juice with natural sugars
And um all the goodness and five a big
Vic the victim vitamin that come with my life has become so not sure how many movies apparently that's the golden cap
Godfather is so good. I don't care for the godfather. Oh, I'll chance a bit chance a bit. I'm not sure about the godfather. Um,
It's a bit well
The dark night
Is that got free installments?
Maybe we do the dark night. I wouldn't mind the dark night with it with Heath Ledger that one
Did it finish did he did the Heath Ledger finish the series didn't I?
Oh, I do want to watch austin powers. Why please do it before the peeler. Oh, no
We have to watch austin power
Hmm
I've never seen back to the future actually
All I know is that his mum wants to bone him when I'm like, oh, this is my kind of pot
Oh, who was it?
Oh, who goes there identification? Sorry. I'm like, uh, my fork is hitting the ball
It passed away are you squinting me right now?
I subbed to your patreon to listen to the clapping hands clapping hands
I'm just ASMR and I have to say it was a great listen
Yeah, I've never heard anything like this in my years of being of tuber. Oh my god
I hope you do this again in the future. Yeah, sure. Jeez. Thank you for the 20 jason. I'm glad you enjoyed it
Thanks for the support on patreon as well. That's hilarious. I'm glad you enjoyed it. It was just a stupid idea
I was like, oh, I can clap without using my hands. So I'll make an ASMR about it like ha ha ha
Um, and I just went for it. It was just like a silly idea
I'm glad you enjoyed it. That's funny as anything
Hmm
Okay
All my chips are gone. I've eaten chips. I've finished a drink. I'm gonna have a sip of water now
Could watch alien if you ignore the force no one likes the force
Hmm
Yeah, that audio wrecked me. Who lost to the audio admit it right now. I want to know if you lost
Can you it's just me jumping up a boom
I lost to the audio I lost you lost you nailed
Yeah
Not beating the alley the alley gunkies about having a dump being veal or
I am going to do a big burp
This is why I can't eat and be on make at the same time
Oh
Please tell me someone just taped my dick twitched
I'm so sorry. I'm so sorry
Like I just um, I do apologize, but I can't help but that had reverb and everything
I
Was so fun that one had depth to it. I could feel it coming. I was like, well, that's gonna be a burp
Yeah
Mukbang ASMR is going to be 30%
Oh, maybe I should upload the burp in ASMR is by 2k or should I make it a normal one?
No, I posted a normal one for one key. So for the second one, I'm going to put another meme one
I have a burp in ASMR that I've already recorded. It's just me drinking coal and water and burping all the way through it
And before that gets a warning
No, that wouldn't get surely surely someone can burp on youtube.com surely does not get that bad
I'll see I'll edit and see if I think it's bad or not because I don't want another warning
Uh burping ASMR. Yeah, that's right. We have no manners here. I was raised in a barn
I'm just probably gonna get some weird comments. Look as long as you guys are happy. I'm happy
I provide the weirdness you indulge in the weirdness. Oh, oh my god. It's my gen name indulge
Wow, I wonder why a name does indulge. It's almost like you're to indulge in the girls
Crazy concept. All right muffin time
You're breathing it's not like
So on it. I don't want a burping interest, but you may give me one. Have mercy, please. That's hilarious
I remember
Someone was like, wait, why are you guys in a burping and they're like imagine
She slobs down. She finishes the ink sample and then burps
Because uh how hard she was eating the the ink sample
I do have mercy in around five hours
Uh
Did I even hit that properly? Sorry, let me do that again. I do have mercy in five hours
Thank you
I'll be here for a couple more hours until we read into Zoro so I can take a quick break
And then I'll make sure me and mercy can see
I even connect to the same game server and before I show you the internet
Boo
I set her up for that. Thank you. I'll steal it myself. Um
The real funny is actually the reeflings and not me. I just yank your jokes and then play that
I was thinking of adding a few more sound effects, but I'm not done it yet
Ah, my muffin's falling apart
Ah
I'm almost there. I'm okay. I'm going for muffin
Yeah, what's next on the roster of fucking eating?
Maybe
Maybe one more
I need one k more wines and then I've reached my goal as Zoro comes on in three hours. I've got plenty of time
What were we even sweating for?
Burping is only when
It's someone you're attracted to it's the same with the peeler stuff. Ah
You know on the golden
Uh, I think I might be pushing the upper limits of the AI at the moment
So please do excuse me if I drop any conversation. All right, I'll do it
um
As I said, I literally do not have one piece of content that's limited ads because of um
The upper I'm very aware of how the AI works. Um
And you know how it can do like live transcriptions or whatever type thing
Um, I am able to skirt them one because of my accent
Which is fantastic because it cannot for the life of itself figure out my accent for a wee bit
However, AI technology is adapting at a incredibly fast rate
Which makes me nervous for when it does catch up with the old Scottish accent
Um, which is why we're probably going to just become multi-cultural and just have like a billion different
things
Uh, Scottish accent doesn't count
Hey, literally if you ever look at the closed captions on my streams
Like especially when I go super scots like I'm mucking about with that accent or whatever
It it doesn't have an it does not even comprehend one earth. I'm trying to say
I don't understand it. Um, which I think helps me with all my
Skirting of the the conversations we may or may not be having
Mm-hmm
Okay, I've had some water
Yeah, in general it happens wherever AI fears the scots. Can you understand us?
Scottish accent is an enigma to the human brain as well. So I think you're safer a bit until you all become scots with me
so
All right, I'm gonna finally open up this bag of raisins. So I commit to eating some of them because I've had them for how long
Oh, jeez I can't oh, it's
Oh, okay, we're in we're in
Oh that smell rather
My smell of smell smells delicious
All right, let's who wants a chocolate covered raisin and please don't make fun of me for liking chocolate covered raisins
I really like chocolate covered raisins. Okay. They're a nice snack
um
Oh, no, there's shit
I spent so much money on the
really shit
No, this can't be I spent so much money on it. Can you be shite? I'm not loving it to be shite
Yeah, the reason reasons are nice. You guys don't like raisins
Oh
I'll tell you something that might filter you from me. I like oat and raisin cookies. I actually think they're the bee's knees
You get a nice buttery oate cookie. It's delicious
You get filtered get filtered get filtered
I think they're nice. You get a nice buttery homemade one. They're so good
Hmm
I think some variant of scots was used in world war two for announcements so the germans couldn't keep up
That's hilarious. You know that you've no been talking on this. Have you?
Those aren't rabies raisins she be was over earlier. Oh my god. This is like completely off topic
I think I've said this before maybe I haven't
When I was a child I used to poop like rabbit poop
And you may be like what?
Yeah, and my my little poopies look like little rabbit poops
I don't know what the heck was wrong with me as a child, but I just thought you should know that fun fact
And now you know you're cursed with the knowledge
um
I don't know what it means
Actually, you know what let's google it. We're in the
We're in the age of technology
Um, let's google it. Why do my I look like rabbit
Um
Signs of a low fiber diet. Wow. I had no fiber as a child. Am I surprised? No, um
No, I am not surprised I had any fiber as a child
um
I was a bottomless pit as a child. Um, I've been very lucky
And was blessed with the skinny milinky long legs gene
Um, but I put it to good use by giving myself a returned butt
You have no fiber now
Google's gonna say it's claude or something
I substituted that word. I know what word you did use but the mall is funny
Um
Wait, are you a rabbit in real life? Yeah
You are not a cull. You are here. I remember it took me so long
I was like, why on earth did she be called a fan base hero? I don't get it
um
I could get it. I don't understand
Hmm this is a shit cup of tea. I can tell you that much
I'm definitely adequately fed and warred though. I don't even need the nature valley bar. I don't even need it
Um
Okay, thank you for allowing me to do the one of the nastiest burps I've done so far on stream
Um, and rehydrate and refueling. I no longer feel lightheaded. So we're we're doing good. Thank you for
Putting up with me. I know some people don't like eating sounds. Uh, do apologize if that is not your hang
um
And I completely look at different strokes different folks. Okay different tickles of pickles and all that jazz. You know how it works
Who's that?
You can do better. I trust you. I don't know if I could freaking out do that
The the biggest burps I have is when I eat because I get trapped wind as a swallow
Thanks for the stream mom my fish. Good luck when meeting. Bye. Bye. We eat me getting ready for stream
Yeah, you're getting ready for stream. We eat me. I bet you are
Strokes and pickles cool knowledge of you
I'm okay with your burps. You're conditioning me towards it. That's terrible
I prefer the aid burping so disgusting this entire agency burps. Yeah, okay
You don't burp. You don't burp when you're at home. Chief
You have to remember we sit in our bedrooms memeing on games
But what makes you think we're uncomfortable here?
From around these parts we burp with our mouth wide open
I don't know where you're from where you're all you all got your your little uh manners
You got manners and stuff chief get your manners out of here. They did you know manners are set and I'm just
Burping makes you real you need to more spinach or whole grains and
General also I found out during the mid-diet granola bars are terrible for nutrition
Oh, are they?
I freaking bought some for stream for when I do endurance days with I can't like I can't make foods
That food literally
Did you know AI so advanced I can make music now
It was only a matter of time. Oh, there will be there will be a song made out of only my burps
I actually so obviously in the day and age of AI technology
Um, obviously it is a very hard field to navigate because of the implications of how many jobs it can take and how many
livelihoods it um affects
um
And I am no exception. Um, you know
If you want to be like mega serious the biggest example of like AI taking your jobs as v-tubers
There's none other than uh neurosama
And people like thousands of people watching AI to stream. Um, it's quite it's really magnificent if you look into it
It really is um
But like it obviously, you know artists, you know artists any like it
I mean freaking hell me for example, like I didn't really want you to feed my voice
And then I did consider possibly AI singing of my voice because I cannot sing um due to
Um vocal damage. Uh, unfortunately, I've damaged my vocal cords successfully. Um in all my journeys that I
I can't sing the way others can sing, you know
Um, if you didn't know you can't actually train yourself to sing over time
But I have like perma damaged myself and I've nerfed myself basically
So I did think I did think like would AI song be
Acceptable in that instance because I can't produce what the song is but I can feed
An algorithm my voice to make that song and then it makes it sound like I'm singing type thing. Um
Um
But then I'm like
No, because that's kind of like it's it's a very interesting like morals are coming into economies coming into it
Everyone's got a wee piece and a wee side thing. Um, and it's very curious. I'm I'm interested to see where it's gonna go
It's very nerve-wracking as a content creator. However, um, because um
Content creation basically relies on
People to fund it. Um
type thing like obviously I'm a bit different because I'm already like self-funded if that makes sense. Um
But like if people were to like just straight up stop supporting and being like well this AI posts it for free exactly what I'm looking for
It's like these are real people
But then you could start to argue like well that happens with any sort of medium like if there's a better competitor that comes up
Well, yeah, they've lost out on their business and their pension and their business shuts down
That's just the way it is in this market
um
So it's kind of hard to even get into a real
Mitty bit of whatever the conversation might be when it comes to AI because there's so many nuances that can come up
But these nuances are valid in the conversation topic. Um
It's a double edged sword really it can help smaller game studios or indies produce games faster
On the other hand it can put others out of business. Yes, the creative field
it it's very
Obviously we're kind of aware about the sinister nature of what AI has been up to recently with creating um
fakes which is a shame because I don't think anyone should be subjected to that. Um
You know, I'm I mean obviously as a creator
I mean I have a bias and I'm like if no one wants that stuff out there
Don't put it out there if they delete it then let it be deleted type thing
Um, but that's just my two cents. Um, but I
I'm aware that on the other side of a viewer being like this person provided me a lot of comfort these videos provided me a lot of comfort
and
Yeah, the world ends when AI can write software that actually functions at a high level without tweaking
I'm about to tweak it
Uh, I can burp in without holding my hand in front of me. I got hit too much on the back of my head when I was young from
Oh, sorry. You got whacked as a child
That's not good
Did you know it actually throws your nervous system out if you get whacked as a child for correction reasons
Content creation is enjoyed for the creator's personality or knowledge. So I doubt AI
Well, see you say that but then my counter argument is Neurosama right now
Thousands of people watching
Algorithm essentially a machine learning algorithm
um
It's fascinating. It's really fascinating
It is and obviously, you know, you can be like
Oh, you're just to be here. You're mad because bought it bought doing better than you and it's like no
I'm trying to I'm trying to explain the side of like
This is a a machine
That has been programmed
Blade blade runner blade runner there there. That's how I'll connect the dots blade runner
How about that?
you know
I think AI is an inevitable
It needs
It's very it's probably what I think is going to happen with AI is it's going to explode
Everyone has access to it. Then laws and regulations catch up to the explosion, but the damage will already have been done
I think
That is what's going to happen my the reasoning. I think it is a blow up and then catch up but damage is done
YouTube
In the internet as a whole starting off as baby
Everyone is catching up to what in real life laws there are because the internet and in real life are two different things
I think we can all agree on that
And a reflection of this is the current ongoing
card
Sorry, my throat was burping card payment processors
They are actually
catching up to almost in real life
laws and things
And it's not treating the internet differently. So one of the biggest examples right now is patreon is no longer allowing
um
artwork that depicts um
Any possibility of cnc
Even though the artworks are artworks and not real people
But that's because mastercard is bending their arm behind their back because of in real life laws
Like the internet is being caught up to in real life laws. Does that make sense?
Hopefully that makes sense
Doesn't the people watch uh dj and stuff like pranksters you use an ai to enhance your content wouldn't be that bad in the grand scheme of
Yes, but I didn't what what what makes me hold back from aiing my voice to do song covers is
One it loses its charm because it's not my croaky voice
two
It's it's not a statement of endorsement. No, however, I think it's definitely a like, uh, that's a shame she uses ai
cncio
content
uh con con
Is what cnc is someone someone type I can't type what it is what you
Laws become uh antiquated fast even when they do come out. Yes, it's um very interesting to see how the
Interwebs are being navigated at this moment in time. Oh, I lost it because I was reading we got 72 000 pop. That was fantastic
um
Yeah, it's a
I like the deep diving in the convo is like this. I know like people like shout out shout away
Oh, I don't want to get into it. I don't want to get into it. I want to get in a I want to see what your thoughts are
I want to tell you what my current thoughts are you might change my mind. We might come to a different thing
We may talk about this. I don't mind talking about these things
I think it's nice. I think it's refreshing being able to talk about it. But I mean, that's for me
Fake version of that. I am she's making winds with
I don't I can't even translate that
but yes, um
l'ma the least ethical players are
Are stealing their data. Yeah, I think a france
um
A french like art school got done for using AI and it was like the most ironic moronic thing and everyone was like, bro
The AI conversation goes into politics easily. It's because the laws need to actually catch up, which I think maybe
um, why?
Probably leaks into that a lot
But anyway, what do I know? I'm just
Uh, a cuttlefish that wants to drown all of humanity to he what happens if it wasn't humanity
Oh, sorry, someone wants to trade my apologies. Hold on. Let me make space. Hold on. Let me just connect these winds
What's going on here? What's going on here? Right? What's going on here?
Oh, you give me a what wait? Why is that worth 15k for that one wine?
What is
half full wine jug
What wait, can I half drink? Why is that so much money? Am I going crazy?
Wine of jug four
Oh
Half wine jug 18k
Infinite moneymaker glitch
Question mark. Can I like half drink these wines and make like a stupendous amount of money?
Um
Am I going crazy?
Half wine. Why how do I get half a wine? Can you drink used drug used jug? Sorry
No, dang it. Wait, how do you do half?
What that's bizarre
What is it?
How do you get half you have 25 million? Why do you need look we're here to be billionaires so we can
bribe the politicians to put in stuff that's actually against it for our interests
It's a rare item that comes with events. How bizarre. Okay. It's the same reason burnt fish sells for something. Oh, I guess
Well, it's main. No, thank you. Or do you want the wine back? You're allowed to have it back. By the way, you can just ask
I'm not actually going to keep it. I'm just surprised. I didn't understand
A brave politician. Oh as long as it interests their bank account
And uh, you can pretty much pass whatever you want. As long as you got the the funds to cough up
Which is why velour is going to be a billion dollar enterprise so we can change the world
I'm just kidding. We are just anime girls on the internet. We're looking for some ink. Okay
Yeah, it's called lobbying. Yeah
And not the good kind of cod lobbies the bad kind of cod lobbies
Back in my day wine used to be drunk in two gulps leaving behind the half wine after
We're getting old
We're getting oh, sorry. Just put that momentary again. We're getting og old scoop lore
Geez, can I finish the sense right? I'll finish this cup of tea before I finish my next sense
Vealers already changed me for sure
Is it black croc? I've changed show but
Strani's opinions do not represent veal or yes, I have to say that like unironically every stream
Please do not be like Strani said this so I'm not supporting any of the girls. One. Don't be a fucking pussy
Of course, I do not speak for all the girls. You absolute
Um and two
Why am I not let's go on an autistic rant by everyone else's there'll be rude
Is it because I'm Scottish be honest
On the original older version game the wing joke is upwards of 40 bell
Literally let me go on my right
What's these things I'm uneducated about and have a little opinion on what oh you shouldn't talk because
Because oh you shouldn't have an opinion on things. You're not educated
Uh, what do you think having a brain is about? Uh, what do you think about the learning is about?
You know, you can present your information for me
What you struggling with what concept do you struggle in with quick quick quick?
What concept are you struggling with tell me and I'll talk about it later, bro
Sorry, I'm arguing with people that aren't even they aren't even here. There aren't there's no one in this room right now
There's no one seeing anything mean at all. I'm just arguing with potential
Arguers. I'm absolutely losing it. I'm so sorry reef lens
anyway
Why ain't anyone
I'm absolutely losing it me at the convention just straight up swinging on reef lens
Oh, no, that's such an
Unmeaned thought I don't like that idea on my head. She's arguing my ghost
You want me to take your meds?
Arguing with the voices
She's arguing with the restless spirit of her toenail rip toenail
It's um
Not as bad as I I thought I I pushed I I would I would confess my sin
I pushed through the bandage to see what I'd feel
um
I'm not gonna push it for a while because one that hurt uh ow
and two
Ow and three
I don't I couldn't really tell what I feel. I think it just feels like touching a normal flesh really
And
But yeah, definitely not touching it again for a while because that's done
I'm on basic painkillers now. Um, it's it's not
It's really no that bad. It's really no that bad. Um
Um
It's probably just gonna be a patience thing now. Um, because it takes forever to heal
Actually, I should go out in the garden and get some sunlight and me to help heal it off, but
I want to play rinse
And then I want to play goose game with mercy
You can take your frustrations out on us
Strenuous myths online that all visitors have a voice in their head. I can like argue with myself
I'm not even being funny. I can just straight up start having arguments with myself about stuff
Like that's why I like when I do actually go like off the rails on my wee rants a little bit
It's because I'm in my head. I'm talking to someone that doesn't believe it
And I have to explain it from the start like as if you were an alien and you've never heard about this before
And I'm like and that's why I'm always like and another thing and another part of this like, yeah
Your britain d levels are probably in the gut. No, the sun is too dangerous for me
I need to go back to pale scotland
Um, I'm actually in danger of the sun if you didn't know, um skin cancer in
Australia is no joke. We
We uh, hung
Oh, wait, I don't think you're not let's say that terminology. My apologies. Don't don't mean to offend
We pasty white ghosts are actually not really supposed to be on Australia because uh, we are not suited for the sun
The sun's rays are extra strong
Um
And uh, yeah, isn't it winter there? It is but the sun is still very strong. It doesn't matter
The uv rays just because it's cold it's still there. Oh my god. My freaking tea is cold
Because I can't stop talking I don't think I've had a warm cup of tea in weeks
Oh
Ozzie and kiwi bro suffering from the sun
Yeah
Half Aussie half Scottish will you actually no no no full scots
If you ever want to run a business and you can pick between scotland and
Australia do it in Australia you get to keep more of your money
And then go back to scotland. I mean I'm going back to Scotland
I I my my pasty white people need me um, and we're having the refund farm in scotland anyway, so
Yeah, it's uh
Don't get me wrong Australia beautiful country. Love it. Love the sun. Love my chinese auntie
Love my granny. I love all these people
But I am not suited for this country. I am I am too used to the most oppressive ways of the uk. I really am
Got a brew of tea forget about it microwave it then. Uh, do not ever suggest microwaving a tea in my presence
You have to start are we raising shape?
The farm needs eggs because we need protein
um
I don't
want
I think we just need eggs on the farm reflands
and then we can have like
I can make like scrambled egg pepper like from peppers and we grew in the garden
And then that can be our wee breakfast and then lunch can be a wee sangha
Would we have wheat production and flour?
Would we have a flour mill on the farm?
Thousands of chickens to feed us. I think we need like eight
Hens lay us and and say I did my research on chickens
I actually did my research while I was away on holiday wink wink um for a year. Uh
So chickens lay eggs for
One to five years and then they are considered an elderly chicken and no longer lay
Most people just perish the chicken when it stops laying
I couldn't do that if a chicken has given me eggs for five years and it stops
I am not going to perish it because it can no longer do it. I want it to live
It's happy little chicken life in the garden. Okay, like um, some people are brutal with their way
Uh, their wings their chickens. I said, I guess the chickens are our wings roofland. Um
But yeah, I they like can lay a lot
There's also the possibility that we would need
Ducks on the farm because ducks are natural pest control for slugs and stuff
So for because I I want to go like natural
I don't want to use like harsh chemicals or anything to like grow production wise like
Um fertilizers all that stuff that's bad for the environment
Um, but ducks and chicken are fantastic for getting bugs and stuff
But the chicken could not be allowed near the crop harvest because chickens will destroy the crops
However, ducks do not destroy the crops. Um, only chickens destroy absolutely everything
They can pot their little beaks can get on because they are
Destructors they also
Stir up stir up the soil
So if we need natural fertilizer, you can like just straight up scoop it and shove it on a plant bed
Then it's pretty good
Your chicken was eaten by weasels weasels
Aren't weasels small aquatic animals that are like long like a noodle
A weasel are weasels, but what?
A weasel weasel
A little small on aqua a weasel yoink your chicken isn't the chicken bigger than the
Weasels are land based
Oh looks like a little noodle
That yoink to chicken
That thing can take down a chicken. It's tiny
Hold on. Let me pull up the picture. I'm looking at right now
Uh, they look toy they look like a pet
If I can pull up a picture anytime now, right hold on. Let's let's go be cheeky picture in
Hmm
This is what I see
This yoink to chicken this that yoink to chicken
It's tiny
Unless they're like a lot bigger than I imagine
Weasels are deadly shut up. These are deadly animals. Look at the freaking look a cutie looks
I've been trolled humans can yoink ostriches. Oh, well you do actually have a point there hold on a minute
Hold on that reefland speaking the truth. Hold on pause
Okay
They're cute till they open their mouths
Is that like me a matty?
Yeah
Okay, maybe if it's like me a matty
They look like ferrets. That's not a thought. Do you read the red wall series? There's a reason weasels are the villains in it
No, I haven't read that actually. I don't know what it is
I don't know what red wall is but that's okay
Because I
Means I can experience media that you guys enjoy. No, you're cute even after opening your mouth
Hmm
Rod red wall was game of thrones for kids. That is hilarious as a description
um
Is there a cat in here or am I losing it? No, it's the heating. Sorry the heating's come on and it's moving the blind
And it makes me think that Vigo is on the window, but he's not
And before a cat jumps up on the table and I get heart attack of a lifetime
It's trying to you're cute when you open your dash straight
You're not
No, you're cute, especially when your mouth is open
Good
That's the way I like it
But yes, uh, I will try my best to
Actually properly update my youtube because now it looks all terribly wrong
But it's going to be bulk troll for two hours spout roll. Sorry for two hours. And then it's going to be
Um member stream for two hours and then that's a four hour day
Which means I might actually have the energy to edit and do all the things I need to do
um
I liked moss flower a lot
In moss flower there was an evil cat who had a bunch of mercenaries who taxed the forest animals and then
Other folk went and killed them
I should actually is robin hood
This is going to sound so silly
And if it is silly, it's okay. You can laugh is robin hood like um actually based on a novel that
and not just that disney tv show
um
Because if so
I'm here for robin hood not gonna lie
He actually kind of he had a few good points, you know take from the rich that I'll never even notice that that's gone
It is okay. Maybe we should read that
Would you replace hypnotica? There's a cuttlefish in the game. Oh
I might give it a cheeky shot. Um
I don't know how hard should I play the game blind or should I look up
gameplay
So I am not completely clueless
Because the reason I can play velcro on stream confidently is because I've seen someone play it play it blind
Play it blind blind. It's fine. Okay. I'll trust you
um
I will stick it near the end of july for subnautica
How about that deal?
Near the end of july we'll do a subnautica. I'll do it blind and
We'll see if my fish friends are going to be nice to me at all robin hood is not based on novel
He's a legendary figure in folk folk lore
The early stories about him dating back to 14th century were shared through oral traditions
I'm gonna share some oral traditions with me
Look I had to think about it on the spot. I couldn't change the sentence up that much
I mean I kind of lose its potency, you know
Oh, well, I will I try
Hmm
Well the character is in public domain is there a robin hood video game are you thinking that
Robin Hood, but it's a girl the classic twist
And then people get annoyed because it's gender changed
But actually it just brings more publicity and yet again we have fallen for the bruce of the marketing campaign
We can't escape it
Fools I tell you fills we are
Yeah, I'm sure you're skilled in oral traditions. Yeah, I want to find out
I think I'm doing
I can't remember what me fucking
Audio supposed to be that comes out tomorrow
I can't believe I'm actually gonna have to wake up an hour early for stream so I can edit that and get it all ready to
Publish because I've not edited it yet because I'm a naughty naughty
Are we talking about that and fire entire fate franchise fate
Oh my gosh, we're in the 49,000s. We're no longer in the 50,000. Let's go Omri five. Let's go. Sorry. I timed out because I was reading
Hey
Congratulations, you just advanced the cooking level. You just advanced our cooking level your cooking level is 85. Let's
Go. This was my goal
for today's stream and we did it. I wanted 85
I'd be self plenty of time for Azor to come along
You're now a quarter of the weight in a night. Don't
see such heinous things in my presence
I am
Look, if there's any doubters, I'm gonna be honest. I'm doubting a little bit
We'll see what happens by the end of the movie marathons
and
If the movie marathons are fine, we'll see where we are
But you're making me nervous saying that I'm only one fourth of a way there
I'm getting a bit shaky and not the good kind because I'm like
bruh
This is insane endurance
I'm not sure like if
If I finish this batch of 49,000, right?
Surely that's my 99, right?
That's 99 if I finish these wine. Yes, you'll be done. Okay
Okay, I have faith because we started at 53,000
And we're already in 49 so I have a bit more faith now
I'm getting my resolve tested roughly 48,000 needs to be done. Right. Okay. If it's 48,000
I can I can do it. Okay
Give me one
Endurance stream where we watch video games where we watch movies whilst we do this then I think we can do it
I don't know. Maybe there'll be two back-to-back like movie streams
Just so I don't have to think and I could be like, uh, grape goes in water jug
Movie on the bunga basically
um
For meme ASMR just read the wiki page on the kingdoms of scotland
Yes, I am going to do a movie watch along the next time we play runescape
So I don't have to think basically and we'll see how much we clear in one of those streams
And we can just enjoy the movies for what they're worth copyright laws. Oh, no, no, no, no, no
You do not know how we do watch alongs in this house
We have a timestamp and you're gonna see where we are, but we do not get copyrighted in this house. I assure you
You'll just have to show up to the runescape stream to see what dastardly plans I have in order to do a watch along
Hmm
Blade runner or alien watch along strongly expected us to be mine
Little didn't know it's gonna be me. That's mine broken by the end of this honestly. I thought 99 cooking was easy
I'm sorry. I actually genuinely thought it was easy. I take it back. I take it all back. It's not easy. Oh, I hate this
Well, I don't hate it
I just I'm like
Feeling a bit overwhelmed because I'm like, oh my god. This is actually going to I can't believe it
I can't believe this achievement in runescape takes a while that barely any players have actually achieved
It's a free 99. Is that why it takes so long?
And before we could like swap to fletching and get it done when the day
That would uh
Actually be pretty hilarious. Just be like, all right. We'll do 99 fletch and write runescape series over when we got a 99
I'll take it. Cooking actually is one of the most common feels good, man
See everyone just wants to know how go do agility 99. Absolutely not
I don't know much about agility, but absolutely not. I know for a fact that's a nightmare one. I think
Is it rune crafting is a nightmare one as well?
I think
thieving if I recall correctly
Thieving is you pickpocket some guard from level 72 onwards. You just do the exact same thing for ages
I cannot believe this is what prime runescape gameplay is. I'm so sorry, but it actually is as well
Like it doesn't get better than this
It doesn't get better than looking into your inventory pulling stuff out putting it back in again
Mining is actually pretty bad. Hmm
Is wood cutting the only one that you can like actually or is it sand crabs?
Is it sand crabs you can afk like you're attacking damage on?
But you still do need to be on standby or something. I can't remember
I don't think there's any true afk like unless you count like hitting a tree
afk
um, I don't know
You can afk the knight in combat easy. Oh
Peak gaming, uh, I prefer pyramid plunder to arby knights, but each of their own
ardy knights
You can do alchemy
I
I don't know. I don't know. I don't know. I think maybe once we hit 99 runescape. I'm definitely taking a big break from it
I do genuinely thoroughly enjoy the game. I wouldn't mind doing questing again
I actually thoroughly enjoyed doing the quest with everyone
and
I do not have much experience with the quest and plots so I wouldn't mind doing it like um
At some point, but I'm talking like this is probably august if we're gonna if we're gonna runescape 99 this
It's probably august until the next runescape
content comes out because
It's um, although the questing would be fun
You gotta go members request. The real question is without help at what point should we be, you know
If you didn't have help and did like if you
And you did like barbarians like salmon maybe if you did salmon
I
Mean if he did it whilst I was like streaming other games
You probably would be near the same level if not farther than me because I've just been grinding on other games
baby
I have grown so sleepy after eating all that food
I'm like man. I could really use a nap before this collab. I don't I don't want to
I don't want to I want to put make more progress towards my level
But then again if we're doing like 12 or a shift to watch movies then
It's not even a shift. Let's be honest
What did you do for your work today? I did backbreaking work stacking shelves was doing the chill
The tells had to like clean up like spillages and all that. What did you do?
Oh, I watched movies while leveling up on old school runescape. Oh
Like come on come on mate. Get real
New runescape is like 10 times easier, but the levels are go up to 120. Do they not which is like four times 99
Unless I'm misunderstanding
Well, you already reached your goal for today. Do you want us to tempt you to sleep?
Don't because I think I might actually take a nap. I'm like, well if I need to be full strength for
Mercy's collab. I'm like if I go how about if I take it to nine o'clock is she be gonna be on at nine or she be on now?
Oh, I don't want to I don't want to um be a silly billy
Naps kind of ruined my sleep she'd be live now
I know she's like, but she's gonna be alive for like another 30 minutes if I round it up to nine a.m
Which makes no sense for anyone not in my time zone if I round it up for another 25 minutes ish
Um
The modern version of the game you get a million xp an hour in the slayer skill and you can get like maybe 50 k an hour on here
Oh, wow
You are not messing around
You can sleep am I ask she be
Yeah, can um
Can someone be very kind and bump into she be streaming just say
Strongly wants to redirect to you in 20 minutes. Will you still be on question mark?
Uh, I will appreciate it if you notice someone else has already typed that message
Please don't spam or chat too much because I don't know. I don't know how in sync the reeflings are yet
I mean you guys are actually pretty in sync. You think you think that yesterday, which means pretty entertaining
Uh, yes
I am very tempted for a nap. I've eaten all that food and I'm like I'm unironically barely full of mead and
Like getting sleepy. This happened last time I played runescape. I think this is just such a like peaceful relaxing game
It looks like she's just chatting. She's
She said to late pee don't know
Give her a pee don't
So I can redirect into her in 20 minutes. She says probably till late. What's that mean?
Yes, or no she be a young in 20 minutes
Yes, I know
Tell me she be right. I'll take that as a yes. I'll just make sure I redirect and then I'm going for a nap
And where are you? Oh, Amy's playing with her palace at the level
Hopefully she's having a good stream together with her. I need to learn her name out of respect
I'm such a forgetful. Well, she hasn't even started the game yet. Oh, she's not even started. Oh, okay. That's hilarious
Yeah, I'll it's safe to redirect into sheepsters. Um, right. We will do our 20 more minutes of wines
and then I'm going to be a cheeky sod and go for a nap and
uh
Wake up. Maybe I can edit an ASMR in time. Um
But my eye, I kid you not my eyes are like, um, yeah sleep sleep. I love sleep. That's a yappy dome
It's very easy and at 90 if you do members trees, you can afk for like 20 minutes at a time
Tastes like two weeks more though. Ah, okay
It's afk though, it's good
Oh, I need to pee pee because I actually put liquids in my body for once
I can't believe it. I can't believe hydrating means that you have to pee. It's a terrible cycle
Terrific one. Wow, this has been four hours. Yes. Sorry if you had anything important to do
Hope I haven't distracted you too much
Because I'll level in over here or just stand on a boot
I assume the the reeflings that stand about like outside have already achieved these kind of things
And they're just like them just happy to be here
Because you could be level enough casually on the side, you never know
You'll be eeping. Don't worry the collab vods will stay up. Um
Mersey doesn't have a warning. She's actually been very good
YouTube has not given mersey a warning so I have faith that the vod will not be taken down
Um, and like I don't really see anything too outrageous
My main account got wiped. I'm giving up on runescape. Oh, no
How does an account get wiped if it got hacked they reset it but give you it all back?
Like they reset the stats
I don't even know how you'd wipe an account. I don't like your bank, I guess
Hmm
Brand new account because of you. No, I'm in it. You're in it too deep. Yeah, I got resets
I mean, they should get your name back though, but that sucks
That's all right, our say so cool. Hi, literally mersey the goodest girl. She's like the one I don't have to worry about ever getting banned
She's just so good. I bet you she does come out with some stuff. I just have no clue because
when she streams is
I can catch icy in the morning if I wake up before streams, but recently I've been waking up
Oh, I was up so late last night waiting for this
Fuck and file to upload so I can send it to the editor to test her out and see if we're a good fit for each other
I sent her a women joke. So I hope she doesn't get offended by it
someone clipped me in the
legend is Zelda stream
And so someone was like, oh those
Those rope jewels always freaked me out as a child because they just take your money or something
And ask it in the way they read it
The way they said it was like something along the lines of and then I went oh
Isn't that just what women are or something like that?
And I sent the joke. So if I get fired as a commission, I know what I know what a clip was the one too far
Yeah, someone clipped it and I was like, oh, you know what turn that into a joke and I'll see what happens
and
To I explained like oh, this is what the enemy looks like in the video game. That was me
Yeah, well, I can see your clips. I'm not kidding your clips helped out like I went through my clips and I had a few more to send over
I sent an audio clip of a someone in the other stream was like, oh, you cannae you cannae clap
Your cheeks basically and then like I stood up and instantly did it
I've sent that to be edited in a clip
So I don't know if this chick's going to be running for the hills when she realized what I've asked her to make for me
Or if she's like going to be like solid and be like, oh, this is hilarious for me
Because it's probably quite drastically different from like the regular stuff she gets commissioned for
And I'm just like, oh, here's me. Here's an audio sound of my
Basically as I I stand up like it's so silly. So either she'll be down or she won't but she's Aussie so
I don't actually
um
Expect any issues because Aussies are pretty humorous
Uh got pretty good humor not the clip of the being the boy you're cute
I wouldn't edit it be like that's cheeky
And it probably goes through so many emotions when receiving the videos. Yeah
Uh Aussie internet is terrible. I uploaded
and
So, you know youtube shorts. So take mercy shorts, for example
I have to send off what is known as an mov file, which is
A full transparent file off to the editor the problem with mov files. They are absolutely
Humongous for no reason and no need now. I know you might say why don't you use green screen?
Look at the color of my hair in my outfit. Why don't I use green screen? Don't ever talk to me again. It's such
useless and I'm just gonna um
So it's just easier to send mov files like emmy for example
You say, huh emmy emmy can use a green screen actually emmy can't she has a green jewel on her necklace
Can't use green screen. Anyway, so I it was like 7 p.m. I was getting 8 p.m. I'm waiting for this file to upload
I'm like please upload so I can send this per chicken audio of me clapping without my hands
I was getting
Exhausted and I was like I'm gonna have me fucking sleep and me energy for runescape and then obviously as soon as I came online
I'm like, hi guys like I have all the energy in the world. I kid you know, I leech energy from refunds. It's true because seriously
Billy more, you know blue screen exists too. What's blue screen?
What if I tell you that you can't clap will you give us another demonstration? No
I have to only do once
Cheeky
Um, I sent away five like pre-made edit shorts type things and then I sent away like seven
Stream clips that I thought were mildly humorous two of them might not be able to be turned into a clip due to the nature of them
just like some moments are funny on stream, but they cannot be translated into a youtube short because there's not enough context
There's not enough time and you're limited to less than 59 seconds
Basically less than a minute. Sorry blue screen is like green screen, but blue. Oh
Sorry, I understand what you're saying. Yes. No, I don't know what you mean, but like it's just
MOV files are just to go to the the easiest to
Thingy, but anyway, I got it sent off is the long and short of it. Um, and I got pretty poor sleep unfortunately
Oh
Cuz I didn't get my my full eight hours. Oh, no. I didn't get ever sleep. I'm a little by me
And as much as I'd like for you to visit with Jeremy don't come here the internet quality and price are horrible. Oh
My dad went to Berlin and he absolutely loved it. And he was wanting to go back to Berlin
I might be doing a Europe tour with my dad on ironic clue. Um
Um
It depends what happens next year. Um, my dad might officially be retiring depending on if
You know if I do you're done basically paying for his retirement long story short
Um, but I was wanting to celebrate it if he does retire and I was like
Do you want to go on a european tour?
Because my dad likes traveling around europe like he really likes the multiculturalism of all even though
He cannot speak speak a lick of any
Um
He cannot speak a lick of any of the languages nor does he bother. He's like the oh
He my dad is polite as anything
He's like, oh, hello
And then he'll point to the menu with a smile on his face and doesn't say anything else and I was like, oh, okay
okay, dad
um
But uh, he wants to go back to germany. So I might actually be in germany at one point to be crazy
Congrats on whoever loved it. I also came back after I love you and break just to watch the call fish
I'm dragging yous back into the runescape home
Probs are proud dad. Yeah, he wants to go to berlin because he loved it. I absolutely loved it
I can't remember what mom and dad did in berlin though. No before anyone makes any jokes
I don't want to know what my parents get up to when they're alone in a foreign city. I do not want to know
Um
I think they did like the classic tourism stuff in berlin. I don't know
If they went anywhere
Because I think my mom's pal came along as well. I'm just trying to remember
But my mom and my mom's pal went off to go visit some of the
a monuments like, um
Outfits and that just to like get all the
Cause like you can go see like all this the stuff and that
Um, I think my dad was just alone in the city and he went away for some food and that and the thingy
And just like laughing at the thought of my dad being alone being like, I love you guys
God and yeah
A bit of ironing like uh, uh the thought of my dad trying to speak german of
Why berlin is the ugliest city? Well, let's say it's where the tourists go and I mean there's all is it's very easily accessible
It's very, uh, English-ified as well for tourists and you have to understand tourists like familiarity
So if there's a place that's like, oh, there's got English things about they're gonna be want to go there, you know
Uh, oh god
Spotted in europe
Well, there is the possibility of like going to italy because I want to go and see
Roma and I want to go see
Uh venice all because of assassins creed. Yes. I said it
Yes, I want to go to roma and assassin's creed and uh venice for assassin's creed
No, I don't care if that makes me some weeb gamer. I don't give a shit. I want to see it. I want to see it
um
Going to hamburger to eat the first hamburger
I don't know if the girls are trying to convince me to come to america. Like I'll do it for them
Because azura was like I can't I was at azure sheebie one of them was like, oh, I'll take you out to like either
I'll take you out or I'll make you like a decent. I think azure is actually like a decent cook
I can't remember. I might be a zura. I might just be making that up and I'm going to get sprang
most likely the last option
um
Germans also don't like speaking german. Yeah, if you go to germany visit
It's basically a disney castello. Oh my feature revealer. You are an anime girl on the internet. You are the weeb. Ah
I always say I'm a gamer over a weeb
and
Like azura her freaking anime knowledge is like limitless. Holy crap. I'm like, uh, I just play expo 360 games to be honest
And I'm stuck on the nostalgia of them because I like familiarity
Uh, although saying that and each of her means I get to like try games for the new time
Like I will not stop talking about it buckshot relay and needy streamer overload
These kind of games that are actually smaller in length are so
um
Appeasing to the streamer profile if you will
It's why I'm interested in producing games that are roughly no more than four hours in length like wrap it up
Wrap it up. I don't I don't want to be playing the same game for like ages
I think it is very uh
Obtainable to streamers kind of this four hour thingy, which is why I came up with a cookie clicker game
That's actually completable. Um, if you didn't know they're
Uh, the the the og cookie clicker game. Um, it's not completable
Um within four hours unless, you know, wall hacks are on are you doing 360 noscopes through the map?
um
Which is why I concepted a game for the first time in my life like that
Obviously making via lures games kind of giving me a bit of an insight of what happens, but the reality is I've been very hands off
I just explained what I wanted and what I needed
Um and paid for it. Um, I ordered the artwork and stuff. I got some I got an artist that was comfortable with all body types
um
mersey actually previewed
her scene artwork
If you want to check out mersey's alt, um
It's currently getting animated right now and then I need to cut up everyone's voices
And then the game's pretty much ready to ship. Um
Wait, I don't know how long this animator is going to take. I do not know the animator
They were outsourced by the developer for me because I didn't have anyone that did this kind of thing
Um, but it's been a fantastic learning experience behind the scenes of being like I want this I want that
I will do this you do that and then we just you know and came together with the games there. Um
Our save file is a thing in this game
And the VLR game no you don't need a
Oh, there is actually
You get rewarded if you replay the game
I I specifically wanted a 20 minute experience. I think it's maybe each round
Like finish it. I think it takes like 30 minutes to go over like the
to finalize the
Situation I want to be vague on purpose because I don't want to spoil it
Um, but the more you replay it the more you can unlock
Something and not scenes you have access to all of the scenes right off the bat
If you through your first playthrough
But for people who enjoyed it or just want to see you know what the other stuff is
There is a small amount of replayability. Um, and it was a bit important to have a bit of replayability because
Um, yeah, no one I mean 30 minutes and then you're done. I mean
Yeah
Can you save in the game? I assume so
Uh, the game is free to play but I think you can save your progress
So if you are looking forward to a certain
Scene or animation with one of your favorite girly pops from velour then uh, yes, I believe you can access that right away
um
Resident evil you think I play
It do you know it cost millions to develop these kind of games you think I had millions in my back pocket
No, it's a free to access game. I've got cute little artwork to go with it
Girls are voice acted at the cost through this much like okay. Can you save in game? I don't know
Was there a hoon for it? I don't know
I really need a pee but I'm about to end stream
Ah, I can't believe it the peeler allegations. Oh, I can't do it. I actually really need a tinkle now that I know
All right. I've got eight minutes. I can hold on
Oh my god, it's not pee. It's a two. Oh, it's both. It's both at the same time. I'm not gonna make it
So you're super excited millions of gp
You don't have millions. How are you gonna buy the castello? Um, I'm gonna work for it
I will I'm gonna work hard for it. I need to pay my ASMR debts
I need to pay my ASMR collab debts because there's three girls still waiting on my dang edit and I do apologize
But I did record my lines, which is the best part
Pixely rpgs games remind me of
Wow pixel games. Oh, that's so cool. What pixel? Oh
pixel
Pixel oh, that's amazing
Hint hint cough cough nudge nudge
For the gameplay. Anyway, not the actual art. Um
Working on things in this economy
No, I say we steal a castello
Well, we just steal castello santian. We can live in italy surely are the lines fairtile in italy
Shawnee take the mic where you go. No, not yet. As I said, azura has to pass the baton to me if azura doesn't pass the baton
I can I am confirming or denying the aligank the aligankies the aligankies um
of peeler
Uh
Working on things in this. I know I need to work hard. She works hard for the money
and
I need to do azura and ac script next
That's probably one of my top priorities because I want everyone to be 5k by the end of this month
um
And at least 5k
I'll see what happens if I can get some editors to do some clips of the girls and fart some money into them
But me me editors they're gone
All of them are like one of them's like i'm sick other ones like uh, I've got in real life stuff
Other ones let my pc just fucking explode and i'm like, okay. Thanks. Um
We're getting hints. I feel so special and sorry for all the rooflings out here
I always give like a little peeper preview or something in between streams
It's just as a a special thank you for like listening in because I know I'm not everyone's cup of tea type thing. Um
But uh, thank you for tolerating me. Here's some insider knowledge that you everyone gets to know about in about a month's time
You know, I can't I can't stop yapping and releasing all my projects. Okay. I just get so excited
Man, I'm a lot of excitement for my project
They're all lying. They're all gonna play elton ring. I'm calling it now
Wait, who's playing elton ring the girls?
Or did I misunderstand? I mean I misunderstood your message
That's a very high probability. Thank you for tolerating me
A month it's so close. Yeah, the the game
The game production started in february all the everything's there
We're just waiting on the animation sequence because there's an animation scene
when you
Uh, complete the objective
Um, I think I almost just spoiled the game there. You know that. Um
Yes, when you
Do the mission objective? Yep, that's fine to say. Uh, you unlock a scene with a girl
And you take it from there
You take it from there you do that now you play one handed
Um, I'll be very surprised
Uh, yeah, it's unfortunate how many editors are in disposed as
scottles lunches
Yeah
As a game dev myself, is it cool if I attempt to you can absolutely make a fan game. No problems at all. Um
I honestly don't I don't I don't know why all these fucking companies have so many rules as long as it's not like derogatory
Or you're saying shite about the girls like
It's all good. All your editors are playing elden ring right now. Oh
probably
I'll actually have like three guys have a new guy on board. Um
And just like
It takes a while, but I'll see how I go with my
Me me me Aussie editor my girl editor. Actually, I wouldn't mind talking about her on stream if she's comfortable with it
That sounds really weird though. Hey, can I talk about you on stream?
The way you edit my clips
So, okay. All right, you freak give me a moment. Just pay me the money. I'll shut up
Oh
No, it's Johnny spoil in the ending. What tries you to someone no, it's not even the ending. There's like there's rounds
There's rounds and you got pick you gotta pick the girl and there's rounds and if you succeed in your mission objective
You get to
Um, there's also it's not really hidden dialogue
But you can pick the girls in a different order and you'll hear a different line depending on what order you pick them in
but it's not like a
Oh, there's like super hidden
Crazy lore. It's like no you you won't hear that sentence unless you pick that girl in that sequence
It's that kind of thing. You don't actually miss out on anything and then
Um for the ending scene unfortunately the ending scene didn't go the way I wanted it to fucked up
Um
But it's all good in the hood. I actually think it's quite adorable. I think you guys will like it rounds like pokemon
Rounds no, no not like strategy turn base. It's a freak. Yes, boys. Go
It's trying to break in NDAs motherfucker. I am the NDA
No, I don't even
There was a contract signed with the game developer unfortunately because of how much money was passing through the hands
Um, but I mean it's all I mean everything I've seen what I've seen all looks good to me. Um
I think mersey's name is actually wrong in the video game right now and I need to tell them
It's not karam
I I told you that mersey's name got changed very late in development. It's very possible right now. She's called karam in the game
I need to check in with the game dev actually
I've just been running out of time everywhere like everywhere I have ran out of time
And I'm like it'll settle soon and it will settle soon. I just need to get to the stage where it settles soon
I'm just not there yet. Like once um
Especially when my dad comes and sees me
Um, because I'll be doing those like four hour streams. I have to admit
It's probably gonna be a lot easier to like keep on top of everything
um
But like my plans have an expiration like you know, like aw strongy aren't you stretching yourself too thin doing the 1,000
uh
Celebration videos every 1000 one ace more video every 1000
Yeah, but it ends at a certain point and growth is an infinite like it'll slow down like it's definitely it'll slow down
There's no doubt about it. I like oh, but what about the um ace more clubs? You're doing what other v-tubers again?
It's gonna slow down. It's not infinite growth like it's it's
I have a goal of doing 100 v-tubers
I can do it all in one month if I really wanted to um or I can take my time and do it over the span of many months
Like everything everything slows down
It's just obviously debut happened
And then everything exploded and now everything's going to slowly come back like once the video game goes up
Like my next project is getting on a game show for the girls
And then the next project uh Azura's got her lovely donut song coming up next project like it's not
It's not like an absolute hammer in like as I said
We're getting clippers in place now because it was hard to get clippers in place before the girls were producing content because that's not possible
Um reeflings we aim for a million no no do not aim for a million
I'll be happy with a play button
As as myself as strony cuttles and then after that i'm like right we're done
I mean I'll still keep going but I'm not doing like any more celebratory type stuff
You spread scrawny scrawny propaganda on tiktok and instagram
Oh
Right, okay. It's time
I need to go for a pp
Um, I I'm at three million cooking xp. Can you see that you can cooking xp three million?
Yeah
That's fantastic
Okay, I am going to redirect into our lovely
jubilee
um
She be cotton boom. She is playing a game called
Encrypted or something inscripted or something like that
Um
And it's a card game, but it's a bit creepy and thingy
So make sure you got your blanket on if you get a little scared reefling. Okay. I don't want you to get nervous
Okay, I'm going to go for the biggest
Peeler allegation ever
And I'm going to go for a nap so I'm well rested for mercy
So I get to see you again today if you are awake
Please don't worry if you need to sleep during the time
Um, it's not my usual stream time unless I do a marathon then it is my usual stream time
Um, but I get the fantastic role of enjoyment
Sorry opportunity to play with none other than mercy modeste in t-minus four hours
It's somewhat hard to fight what's going on over there. Um
But thank you so so much say hi to sheepsters for me and I will see you in four hours. Okay
Bye. Bye reeflings. I'll see you on goose game. We're playing goose game on the the unlist uh untitled goose game
Yes, okay, right. I love you little reeflings. Have fun with she be she'll look after you
If not, Emil will look after you and her wee funny clap. Hopefully it's going well actually
Um, and I'll see you very very shortly. Okay. Bye. Bye
Why